Five years ago, I was trading making
$100 per trade. Now, I've scaled up to
making over $5,000. In this complete
futures course, I'm going to show you
everything you need to know to
understand how futures work, a strategy
that you can consistently execute every
day and how to take a small account and
scale it consistently to a larger size
like I have done. So, by the end of this
master class, you will know the exact
path to take to start making a full-time
income trading just 60 to 90 minutes
every day. I'm going to go through the
whole laundry list of things that you
need to know and understand about
futures and how they work. I'm going to
just explain you the basics of how
futures work, how they're priced
differently compared to other assets,
why they're actually just better than
other assets. If you ask me, I've traded
everything and I find futures to be the
best. what's margin, how it works,
what's overnight margin, intraday
margin, how they're priced, what is the
best place to actually trade futures,
and we'll go through a lot of other
things and even some tax advantages of
trading futures over other assets. And
so, we're going to start with the basics
and slowly build you up so after the end
of this video, you will be able to have
a trading platform and understand how
futures work and to be able to start
executing a trading strategy with it.
Now, futures work differently than
stocks in many ways, but once you
understand them, it's very simple. Just
like trading a normal stock, if you buy
it and it goes up, you make money, and
if it goes down, you lose money. For
example, though, the big difference is
when you buy, let's say, one share of
Apple, you can hold that share as long
as you want. You own a piece of that
company and it will never expire unless
the company goes bankrupt or is taken
private. With futures, you aren't
actually buying part of, let's say, a
company like Apple. You are buying a
contract agreement that's value is based
on the market it's connected with. So,
for example, let's say you buy one
futures contract in the oil market. The
contract's value will go up when the oil
price increases and it will go down if
the price decreases. The exact same way
a share price of Apple would go up or
down. So when it comes to the
practicality of actually trading this,
there's basically no difference. But the
only thing is the futures contracts
expire unlike shares. The length of a
futures contract can depend on what
market you're actually trading. But
generally it's 1 month or 3 month. This
is the one reason why futures are
shorter term trading asset. It's not
something you hold for a long term. Most
people like me day trade using them.
That's where the real advantage comes
into play. Now, technically, when you
buy an oil futures contract, you are
buying the ability to buy a,000 barrels
of oil at a certain price. That's the
nuts and bolts behind it. But in
reality, you're never going to do that.
You were just using this contract to get
leverage of a,000 barrels of oil because
this contract actually costs a fraction
of the purchase price of a,000 barrels
of oil. but you get the value increase
or decrease of those thousand barrels of
oil. It's the exact same thing as buying
a house with a loan. You only put up the
down payment for the house, let's say
$100,000 on a million dollar house, but
you get the increase or decrease of the
million value of the house, but you're
only putting up a fraction of the total
value in the down payment. Now, in the
trading world, that down payment on the
house is not called a down payment. It's
called a margin requirement. Just think
of it like the collateral that you need
to put up for one futures contract of,
let's say, oil. For example, now if we
buy one futures contract of the S&P 500
futures, which is a different futures
market, this will take about $500 worth
of margin. your account will have $500
taken away as collateral, but when you
sell the contract back, you get the $500
worth of margin back. Now, this isn't
taking into the account the profit or
loss that you made on the specific trade
you took. So, when you see the price of
the S&P 500 futures trading at, let's
say, 6,000, it doesn't actually cost you
$6,000 to buy one futures contract
compared to, you know, when you buy
shares. It's actually based on the
margin requirement at the time. Now, the
market requirement will differ from
asset to asset like oil futures to wheat
futures or from brokerage to brokerage
and time of day. And so, let me break
down to you each one of those
categories. First off, you have what is
called intraday and overnight margin.
So, for example, the US stock market is
only open during the New York trading
session, which is 9:30 a.m. Eastern
Standard Time till 4:00 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time. This is the only time of
day that you can trade stocks that are
in that market. But futures, on the
other hand, are open almost 24 hours a
day, 7 days a week. They technically
close for a short amount of time after
the New York session closes and over the
weekend, but this is how the intraday
and overnight margin difference is made.
If you're trading, let's say, the S&P
500 futures during the New York session
when all other stocks are open in that
9:30 to 4:00 window, you only are
required to put up the intraday margin,
which is generally extremely low,
compared to the overnight margin, which
is anytime the New York market is
closed. So, for the S&P 500 futures and
really any US-based futures, it's going
to cost you a lot more to trade outside
of that stock market open window. Now,
these margin requirements can change
based on brokerage. Some of the
brokerage have the more normal margin
requirements, which can be roughly 5 to
7,000 for the intraday. But other ones
like Ninja Trader, which is the one I
use, can have low margin requirements
for, let's say, the S&P 500 futures. One
contract can be $500 worth of margin,
which is tiny for how much leverage and
potential and profit that it gives you.
But for almost all the platforms, the
overnight margin is never reduced, which
is generally double the intraday margin
or around 15,000 for the S&P 500
futures. Now these are the normal margin
numbers. This can actually change when
market volatility goes up because when
the market goes crazy, brokerages will
see that there is more risk and so
they'll ask for more collateral
basically. So for example, in the CO
2020 market crash, the margin
requirements were double or triple at
times, but it only happens very rarely
in extreme times like this. And so it
doesn't need to be something that you're
super aware of. And generally you should
have enough money in your account to
cover the change. Now another minor
difference between futures contracts is
you have ones like oil where you're
gaining control over a physical asset or
other ones and if you held that physical
asset contract to expiration and used
it, you would get barrels of oil. on
other ones like the S&P 500 futures or
NASDAQ futures, they aren't actually
based on a physical product. It's
actually based on the index that
follows. So, these ones are just settled
in cash. But, if you're day trading or
even just holding them over a couple of
nights, you don't need to be worried
about having to deal with settling the
contracts because it's basically never
happens. I've never had this happen to
me because I always close them out or
what we'll talk about in a minute is
roll them over to the next expiration.
You would actually have to hold it until
the last week of expiration and hold it
probably through the date of it expiring
for that to have to happen. But the
brokerages and platforms will usually
just close you out of the trade as well
before you have to do something like
that just because it's a nightmare on
their end as well. And I'm sure you
don't want to have uh you know a
thousand barrels of oil showing up at
your front door. And whenever it really
gets close to that date, you always
trade the new contract anyway. You'll
even do it a couple weeks beforehand.
And what this is called is it's called a
rollover. And on Ninja Trader and other
platforms, you generally don't have to
worry about it. The system will either
update or send you a message that pops
up and tells you to roll over to the
next contract. Generally, I always do it
a week before because that's most of the
time that I've noticed is when the
volume picks up on the next contract
anyway. And you always want to be
trading the contract with the most
volume. And all this means is like a
Ninja Trader, you are changing the
ticker symbol, which is technically the
contract expiration, to the next one. So
to walk you through what this looks
like, the S&P 500 futures expires every
3 months and it's always the same month.
Essentially, it starts at the new year
and it does it every quarter of the
year. And the expiration week will
always be on the Friday of the third
week of that expiration month. So, if
you have an expiration of, let's say,
3:25, this means it's the third month of
the year 2024 and then will always
default to it expiring the third Friday
of the month. And all you need to do is
it depends on the platform, but at least
on Ninja Trader, you'll generally just
click the rollover button, but you can
also just change in the ticker to just
saying 624 cuz all you're changing is
you're just moving over to the next
month. Now, some platforms will actually
just have letters for the month instead.
You can see right here, this is what the
letter corresponds with the month, and
it will always be the same for every
futures contract, no matter what you're
trading. But remember, some will do it
every 3 months, and some will do it
every month. Now, when it comes to
trading, that $500 worth of margin for
one S&P 500 futures contract is still
massive for a small account. And so if
you're wanting to start with an account
of let's say $500 or $1,000, what you
can do is you can trade what is called
the micro futures. All the main futures
contracts have them and they're
essentially onetenth of the size of the
normal contract size. So for the S&P 500
futures, which are normally $500 margin
to purchase, the micro version is only
$50, but also the price movement is
onetenth of the size as well. So, your
trades are going to be smaller. But what
this does is it allows you, and it's a
super simple way to start and grow your
small account. I did the exact same
thing with my account. I started trading
the S&P 500 futures with micro futures,
risking $50 to $100 per trade, and then
I slowly traded, growing that account,
and I increased that trading size more
and more. and then I eventually switched
to the normal future size of the S&P 500
futures when my account was big enough.
Now, the other important thing about
futures is understanding how the
movement in price relates to dollar
change in your trade. For shares, it's
super simple because their share value
is based off of a dollar value. If your
share of Apple goes up $1, you make $1.
its value is based on the dollar change.
Now, with futures, it's completely
different. First, the price movement
isn't based on money. So, if you're
looking at the S&P 500 futures and you
have one S&P 500 contract that goes
from, let's say, 6,000 to 60,0001, that
doesn't mean your contract value goes up
$1. It actually goes up $50. And this is
called one point. The movement from
5,000 to 5,0001 is called one point.
Think of it just as a numerical change
of one. Now, going back to shares, the
smallest amount they can move is one
penny, but that isn't the smallest
amount the S&P 500 futures move. The
smallest amount of movement is 0.25,
which is called one tick. It's 1/4 of a
point. So, it's valued at $12.50.
Now, this point value and tick size is
different for each futures market. So,
for the ES futures, which is the S&P
500, it's smallest tick size is 0.25 and
that's valued at $12.50. And the point
value is $50. But if we go look at oil,
the smallest amount of movement it can
do is 0.01,
or almost you could say like a penny.
And that's called a tick for oil. That's
the smallest movement it can do. and
that's valued at $10 a tick. So, one
point or one numerical movement in oil
is valued at $1,000, but there's way
more ticks and movements in that one
point of movement. And so, if you look
at the two markets, the amount that they
move is drastically different. Oil moves
in a lot smaller increments. So, the
sizing of the contract value with $1,000
for a point makes sense because it's
generally only moving between $60 to
$80. And, you know, the S&P 500 futures,
which is valued, you know, between 5,000
and 6,000, has a lot more point movement
in between there. Now, one thing to be
aware of is trading futures, you are
overleveraging yourself. for the ES
futures contract. Only putting up $500
worth of margin isn't your max loss.
Technically, you own one contract of the
ES futures market. And if the market
suddenly crashes, you could lose more
than your account or that $500. Now,
this almost never happens. I've never
had it happen to me over the, you know,
five plus years I've been trading
futures. And there's a couple ways you
can protect yourself to make sure this
doesn't ever happen. The first way is
always have a stop-loss in place no
matter what. Never move it farther away.
First off, increasing your potential
risk once you're in a trade because if
the market opens and goes against you
really quickly, this stop-loss will get
you out of the trade as fast as
possible, not allowing you to lose more
than you were planning. Now, you can get
something called slippage, where the
market's moving so fast even a market
order won't get filled at the exact
price. This doesn't really happen that
often and in the end it's not actually
that much money that it will slip. You
might lose a bit more than you wanted
to, but it won't be a crazy amount. The
other way for this to happen, and let me
show you on a chart real quick, is if
you traded and held through the futures
market closing and then opening. And so
essentially what that would look like is
if you entered in let's say a buy here
expecting the market's going to go up
and the futures market closes for an
hour after the trading day every day.
And so you can see here if you entered
in a trade here the market closed right
at this price and then opened all the
way down here. And if your stop loss of
let's say risking $500 was right here.
And let's say your account you know is
$1,000 and you're only planning to risk
a couple hundred here. Well, the best
price you could have done was all the
way down here, which would have been a
couple thousand worth of loss. And so
that's how you could have had an
overexaggerated amount of loss that
could theoretically blow your account
up. So that's the biggest thing that I
would do is never hold futures into an
overnight close or even over into the
weekend when it closes. Basically, when
it closes and opens again, that's your
big window for having an extreme loss
that you can't get out of. And also,
this happens a lot because news or you
know, stock earnings will come out right
after the market closes. And so when it
opens again and you know, let's say
Apple comes out with a really bad
earnings report because Apple's a big
part of let's say the S&P 500 futures or
if you're trading the NASDAQ futures,
it'll make a big drop and a gap like
that we saw in the futures contract that
you're trading and you'll take a massive
loss. Lastly, the only fees that come
with trading futures is generally kind
of some kind of routing fee and then the
commissions that the trading brokerage
you use. Generally, the routing or
trading fees are fixed and will be same
across the board. And then futures
commissions are based on the brokers
that you're using, but because there's
so many big platforms out there and
they're all super competitive on the
commissions, you're not really going to
find much of a difference throughout
them. There's also no interest or fees
with the margin that you use. That's for
different types of margin accounts.
generally trading like stocks on margin.
Also, don't get confused with other
types of margin in trading and investing
that can have interest rates on the
margin that you use. That's when you're
essentially taking a loan out for this.
The margin is more of again, think of
that like collateral or down payment
you're using. And so, really cool about
futures is the tax benefits that comes
with it. Now, I mainly switched to
futures because of the simplicity. It's
exactly like trading stocks, and it's
not complicated like options, but it
gives you the leverage that options
allow. So, it's kind of the best of both
worlds. You know, you buy it, it goes
up, you make money, and you can do it
with a small account and get super crazy
leverage. And then, as well, on the back
end, when it comes to tax season,
there's a really cool rule that is
applied to it. Now, of course, I'm not a
tax professional. This is kind of just
what I know from doing it myself and
kind of on and what's out there just
based on the internet. And so when it
comes down to it, 60% of your profits is
in a way lower tax bracket and then 40%
is in your normal tax bracket. You know,
what you make in that year as a normal
like let's say W2. And so what this
allows you to do is even though you're
day trading, it counts in a way as a
long-term investment or asset. and you
essentially just get to keep more of the
money you made compared to everything
else. You have to hold it for a whole
year before it becomes in that long-term
capital gains category. And so now let's
go to Ninja Trader here and I'm going to
practically show you some of how this
looks like on a real chart. And so this
is looking at the S&P 500 futures, the
ES futures. We're looking at the main
contract, not the micro smaller version.
This is the full contract. And you can
see over here on the left side is this
is the price movement and it's going up
in 0.25
increments. Sometimes it might jump a
little bit more because the market's
moving pretty quickly right now, but
generally it'll move up by 0.25. And
then if I just click right here, buy
market at one contract, you can see that
the dollar amount is going up or down in
12.25 25 increments. And if it moves up
one point in my favor, that'll be about
$50. And so you can see just looking at
we're looking at a one minute chart
right here. The dollar movement per
price is very, very large. We're trading
one contract here. And you can see over
this one small candlestick, I'm already
up like $200. And so you can imagine if
the market just moves up right here,
that's probably like $1,000. And this
move right here that took about 25
minutes with one futures contract would
have been probably like $2,000. And so
you can see the leverage of that money
comes into play massively. You know,
this costed me $500 worth of margin. And
you can see that I'm already basically
up $500. And so the leverage there that
you can get on a tiny account to
potentially make a a huge amount is
really really big with these contracts.
But again, you can see on the flip side
that $500 I was up has all of a sudden
seemed to start to evaporate, right? And
so again, leverage can work against you
or for you. And so that's where you want
to then go into if I then just, you
know, this is just a demo account. I'm
not going to just be goofing around on
real money here. Um, if we go into the
micro futures, you can see it looks the
exact same chart, but if I buy one
contract now, it's a tenth of the size.
It's going up or down, $125.
And so, this is the exact same thing for
everything in terms of if you jump into
a micro futures contract, it allows you
to now start with a super small account.
And these movements for a small account
are a lot more manageable. you know,
instead of risking, you know, $500 for a
small swing, which can seem huge, I
could put, you know, enter in here and
put my stop loss down here and I could
be risking $20 and I could, you know, my
target could be $30. And so this is how
you can start with a really, really
small account and then slowly scale
because then of course to scale up, it's
super easy to say, well, instead of
buying one contract, I now want to buy
two contracts. And you know, see here
this number two means how many contracts
I have. And now it's going up by, you
know, $2.50 instead of $1.25 per tick
because I have two contracts instead of
one. And so you can, you know, that's
how you it's allowed you can you can
easily increment your size as you go up.
And so you can see this movement here
is, you know, now I can target maybe
$200 worth of profit for, you know, a
$50 or $75 risk as you slowly increase
your size when you're becoming
profitable. It took me over 5 years to
make over $9,000 in profits in a single
month trading. Today, I'm going to walk
you through the four steps that if I had
followed when I first started out, would
have got me there 10 times faster. The
real breakthroughs aren't hidden in the
bullet points. they are understanding
the nuances and the little steps that
are inside each bullet point, especially
the last step where I'm going to show
you exactly how to scale your trading
account. If you just skim it, you'll
likely miss out on key steps that
actually make it work. Now, the first
big bullet point is quantity over
quality. This can seem super basic when
you first start out and in some sense it
really is. But I know from experience
and teaching other people how to trade.
Everyone goes through that process of
okay, I've heard that it makes sense.
But the reality is everyone approaches
trading in the wrong way of trying to be
reactionary to the market and what it's
doing. When I first started out trading,
I tried to look at all the moves in the
market and try and see how I could
capture each one. If it was a really
strong setup or kind of an okay setup, I
would still take them because what I
wanted to do is I wanted to capture as
many moves as possible. And that what I
didn't realize was instead to really
become consistent over time and it took
me years of losing to have this really
driven into me is you don't need to be
taking 20 trades in a day. You can take
one trade a week and be consistently
profitable over the long run. This is a
marathon that you are starting or trying
to do. Treat it like one. You do not
need to be treating it like a sprint.
It's all about timing when it comes to
it. And some days or weeks are just not
good for trading. It's all about trying
to have it fit how you want to trade,
especially when it comes to when you're
first starting out. Treat every trade
like you're in a really big account or
like it's real money. If you're starting
out on a demo account, if you wouldn't
take that trade on a real money account
or a really large real money account,
don't take the trade because the reason
why you're taking it is you think it's
not that big of a deal. And you know,
the idea is, oh, you know, it kind of
might work out. The only trades you
should be getting in are the ones you
really, really believe in and that you
know are going to be really, really
good. I've done that countless times
where I get in a not great trade. I
still want to jump in and try and
capture that move because what if it
does work out? Another big thing when
you first start out is don't overrisk
per trade. Don't change how much you're
risking per trade. you know, don't risk
50% of your account on one trade. What
you need to do is you need to risk a
small amount so your account can slowly
grow over time. And as well with this is
when you're in a trade and you have
placed a specific stop-loss based on
your strategy, do not move that
stop-loss farther away, increasing your
risk per trade. It's really common to
get married to a trade to where you
think it's going to really work out and
it's still looking good and you know
maybe the market just needs to go
against you a tiny bit and I've done
that plenty of times and every time it
just makes it so I lost more on the
trade and if I got out where I
originally had it I would have got out
at less and the signal for the trade not
being good anymore was where I was
originally going to get out. It sucks
having a trade that looks so good go
against you and not work out to be a
really big winner. But that's a part of
trading. You don't know when things are
going to work out in your favor. At the
end of the day, we're trying to play the
math game and statistically things are
going to work out some of the time and
not some of the time and you don't know
when that's going to be. I was micro
scalping and trying to take 20 trades a
day and risk a large amount to make a
small amount. And I originally thought,
well, if it's a short distance go for
profit, well, it'll be easy for me to
get that profit. But statistically over
time, it made me so, you know, my wins
were really small and my losses were
bigger than my wins. And what this did
to me mentally, every time I took a
loss, it felt horrible because it would
wipe out multiple wins. It would take me
three wins to wipe out a loss and get a
little bit in the profit. And when it
comes to trading, the mental side is
extremely important because every
decision you make can be influenced by
your emotions. And if you're frustrated,
it's super easy to make bad decisions,
which is something that derails so many
traders from being consistently
profitable. And so when it comes to your
riskreward, I highly suggest starting
out with either a 1:2 riskreward ratio
where you're risking $100 to make $100.
Statistically, you're break even at a
50/50% win rate, which mentally is a lot
better. Same thing if I would also
recommend going one to two riskreward
ratio initially as well if that's what
you would prefer where you're risking
$100 to make $200. I think that's even
better because you only need a 33% win
rate to be consistently break even and
above that you're consistently
profitable with a 40 or 50% win rate.
And mentally, it makes it so your losses
aren't as big of a deal. For me, losing
and having that mental struggle of, oh,
what if I get in this trade and I was
wrong? Having that pressure on every
trade was a lot easier when I could say,
well, if I lose, it's okay. I am
actually based on my riskreward I'm
supposed to lose a majority of the time
which seems really funny but
mathematically it plays out in the end.
Now before we go on to the next step I
have created a 90-day trader road map.
This will lay out everything that you
should go through and focus on other
than this video over the next 90 days.
It'll give you a stepbystep process of
what you should be doing on the road to
becoming a consistently profitable
trader. I'll leave a link for it in the
description below this video or you can
download it for free using this QR code
as well. Now, I think the number one
thing that stops traders from being
consistently profitable is jumping from
strategy to strategy. I did this for
years. I would watch a YouTube video,
take a course, and try and focus and
learn on a strategy, and I would not be
consistently profitable doing it. And
so, I would then move on to the next
strategy. Well, what this did is it
would start me over from step one.
Again, in reality, trading takes a long
time to become consistently profitable
at. Even if you're taking a strategy
from an experienced trader that is
consistently profitable doing it,
everyone approaches trading differently.
We all have different emotions that
affect how we trade differently. I get
scared to jump into a trade because I'm
nervous that I'm making the wrong
decision. Well, maybe you know you're a
person that once you're in a trade,
you're greedy and let the thing go on
too long and you give up your profits or
you take larger losses because you move
your stop loss farther and farther away
because you get married to the trade and
want to let it play out more. Everyone
is different and so that's why it takes
a long time to become consistent with a
strategy. And so you have to stick to
one strategy. Otherwise, you're going to
get stuck in what I actually call now a
learning loop of trying to learn
infinite things about the market. That's
the thing about trading is there are so
many time frames, so many indicators.
And what this all does is it really
makes infinite ways to approach trading
the market. And so how I actually ended
up breaking out of this was after a long
losing streak of struggling and just
feeling defeated, I went back to the
drawing board and said, "Okay, what am I
actually good at?" And I felt I was good
at seeing where key levels of support
and resistance were. I felt that I could
consistently mark those on my chart and
look for reversals at those levels. I
felt more confident trading reversals
than continuation type trades. And so
what I did was then I spent a couple
years developing my own style of okay,
how do I profit off of these levels that
I'm confident in and that I can draw
really well? And so that's where I came
up with my strategy of looking for
trades in the first couple hours of the
US market open. And the most important
takeaway of what this did is it allowed
me to focus on one simple strategy
instead of trying to capture every move
or you know constantly add more things
to the chart either indicators or
learning more patterns to try and
increase my win rate because you know
logically the more you learn about
something generally in life the better
you are at it. Well when it comes to
trading more is not better. more is
actually less when it comes to trading.
Learning more and more patterns or
strategies just over complicate it and
they don't actually increase your win
rate. And so that's why it's very easy
for people to get stuck in that learning
loop because logically it makes sense to
go learn more or learn a new strategy,
but it doesn't actually work that way.
And so I would highly recommend just
focusing on learning market structure,
not really using indicators. You can use
one or two, but do not have a ton of
them. The simpler the better in the
strategy I think because there's so many
variables when it comes to trading. If
you have too many things you're trying
to check off on your list to get into a
trade, you're never going to get into a
trade and it's going to be impossible to
start tracking. And when you start
journaling, which is something I highly
recommend you do, to actually figure out
what's working and what's isn't because
there's going to be 15 different things
that you need to be working or not
working. And over time, that's going to
be impossible to really know what's
making you consistently profitable and
what's not. But what I highly recommend
doing with your strategy that you decide
is you need to write out a plan. You
need to make a trading plan to
consistently follow. What you're going
to be doing every day, your trading
routine, what you're going to do before
you open the charts, how you're going to
look for trades, and prep for finding
those trades. And then once you are
actively trading and you're in a spot
where okay, what do I actually do when I
jump into a trade, you know, for me, I
have like a a four-step simple checklist
to jump into a trade that every trade
needs to match. And then when I jump
into a trade, where is my stop loss
going? How much am I entering per trade
based on my account size? And then where
is my profit target going to be? Am I
going to do a 2:1 riskreward ratio? Am I
going to go to break even at a certain
point? You need to have all of that laid
out and not just up to getting into a
trade. You need to have rules on how to
manage a trade as well. Because once
you're in a trade and there's real money
on the line or, you know, even if you're
demo trading and you're taking it very
seriously and it's still intense, you're
going to become more emotional. And if
you don't have a trading plan structure
to follow, you're going to end up
emotionally trading and making a
decision based on your emotions, which
is not going to be consistently
profitable for you. and it's generally
going to lead to the bad decision. Now,
the most important step when it comes to
building your trading account is how you
properly scale. Now, I've traded just
about every asset there is out there.
I've started trading options. I started
trading stocks. And what I've landed on
after a long time, and what I've
realized works out the best for starting
a small account and slowly growing it
over time is trading the futures market.
But the idea is that you can start out
with risking about $20 to $30 per trade
depending on the volatility of the
market and you can slowly use that to
scale over time. They give you a ton of
leverage as well which is important to
growing a small account or even trading
a larger account as well. And so the key
steps that I would follow is to start
out demo trading first or practice
trading with fake money no matter where
or what strategy you are doing because I
find so many students jump into real
money right away and there is so much
about trading that you are just learning
even just learning the platform you're
going to make mistakes and mistakes in
trading losses you money and so the
switch from going from demo trading to
real money or let's say a prop firm
account is I highly recommend waiting
until you have consistently profited for
at least 2 months. Now the reason
because of this and that kind of lengthy
time is the markets no matter what
strategy you're trading the markets are
constantly shifting and no strategy is
good in every market. There will be
people that trade my strategy that do
really good in let's say a month time
because the market is having really good
back and forth reversal trades and every
aggressive signal works out really well.
But then let's say the market patterns
start to shift. the market starts to get
a little slower, less volatile, and that
trader now is used to seeing all those
patterns work in a certain way, and
they're not able to realize that the
market has slowed down, and they need to
shift how they approach the strategy
slightly. They need to be a little more
patient and wait for a stronger, more
clearer setup and realize that taking
that aggressive entry doesn't actually
work anymore. But instead, what happens
is they take that aggressive entry day
after day when it's not working and they
start to blow their account and give up
all the profits they had. And now they
realize, okay, the strategy just doesn't
work. And, you know, they go back to the
learning loop and they try a new
strategy or, you know, try and figure
out something that doesn't work. And so,
that's why I highly recommend trading
and finding that consistency for a
couple months on a demo trader because
you're going to go through multiple
market cycles in that time. You got to
remember there is some luck involved
with trading because it's just
statistics at the end of the day. And if
you're, you know, just have a good
profitable week, well, you can't just
say, "Okay, I'm a profitable trader and
boom, let's go off and, you know, now
risk $50,000 on a trading account." Now,
once you are confident in your trading
and you make that switch, either switch
to a prop firm account if that's what
you want to do, but I highly recommend
starting out with a real money account
first with a small amount of money
because what this does is it slowly
introduces emotions into your trading,
which is the second key part of becoming
a consistent profitable trader. And you
have to learn how to trade with those
and manage those as you're trading.
trading on a demo account isn't going to
allow you to really unlock that full
emotional side of trading. And so
allowing yourself to start out with a
small trading account and risking, you
know, $20 per trade is what's going to
ease you into that. And then what you
can do is slowly scale over time. When
it comes to account size and risk per
trade, I wouldn't suggest risking more
than 5% of your account per trade. When
you're starting out at a micro scale,
it's kind of hard to go a lot less than
that. But as your account goes bigger,
you know, you get down to risking 2% or
1% or less than that. Risking a small
amount of your account allows it so you
are less likely to blow up your account
by going on a bad loss streak. And when
you're first starting out, you're going
to struggle to control those as much.
And so, you want to give yourself that
time. Remember, this is a marathon. You
want to give yourself that flexibility
to be able to bounce back and stay in
the game of trading. And so that's why I
highly recommend trading futures for
starting and scaling over time. In this
video, I'm not just going to break down
the basics of chart analysis, but the
unique moves and quirks of each futures
market. So, by the end of this video,
you can have a clear understanding of
how to analyze these futures markets and
charts based on what the candlesticks
are doing. And even if you already know
some of that basics, understanding how
these futures markets actually trade and
differ from each other in practice will
completely change how you actually trade
and your performance when it comes to
trading. And so when it comes to
trading, a lot of times you start out
thinking that I need, you know, 10
different indicators on my chart and all
these different things that make it easy
to, you know, know what to do because it
seems like an indicator can just tell
you what to do. But at the end of the
day, if you learn to just do some of
these basic chart analysis things, you
will drastically improve your trading.
And one of those is just learning to
look at the major swing highs and swing
lows of a market. It will drastically
improve your understanding of the
direction of the overall trend. And when
it comes to actually entering in trades,
the biggest factor I always take into
consideration, no matter how good the
more smaller patterns look, is the
overall big picture of what the market
is doing. because that is going to rule
your trade no matter what. It doesn't
matter how good a support level looks or
a trend line looks. If it's coming to a
major area where and your big picture
analysis of a trend is that it's
overextended and it needs to slow down,
well, if you, you know, jump in short
right here and you weren't looking at
just that big picture, you're going to
be losing a lot more trades than you
want. And so the basics of, you know,
downtrends and uptrends are made by the
market making lower lows and lower highs
where just the swings are getting lower
and lower. An uptrend is just a flip
where it's making higher highs and
higher lows. And this really helps you
just this basic structure helps you stay
on the right side of the market of
saying, "Okay, well overall this thing
is mainly making lower lows and lower
highs." There can be some times where,
okay, it gets a little back and forth
here where it has a uh, you know, right
here, it had actually more of a quick
uptrend before it continued its
downtrend. So, that could have just been
a pullback in the major downtrend that
was taking place. And this can also
happen because what's happening is
you're at a transition period where you
are going from a downtrend where it's
making consistent lower lows and lower
highs and then all of a sudden it starts
making a higher low and then a higher
high and it shifts to an uptrend. So,
you're going to have these areas and
these are really key to start to learn
is have areas where it starts to shift
and you want to be aware of that because
that's when the trend is starting to
change. If you're either in a trade
betting that it's going to go down,
well, that's usually a signal to get
out. Or if you're looking for the market
to reverse to the upside, well, you can
take that into account for going long
and taking a reversal trade and trying
to buy the bottom of the swing. And so
super helpful thing with identifying a
lot of the swings in the market. And
this is just going to take you time to
understand is going through and you can
use things like a trend line. And so how
I like to draw trend lines is if I just
use a quick drawing to kind of show you
before we look at the charts cuz no
chart really looks like this. But a lot
of the time what you want to do is you
want to essentially just match the
highs. The idea with the trend line is
you're matching it to all the main swing
highs that you're seeing. And then on
the flip side, you can also make what's
called a channel where essentially it's
both where the market doesn't do this a
lot of the time, but it can sometimes
make a channel where on the upside where
the pullbacks they will respect a
downtrend. And then on the the swing low
side is they'll also basically be
respecting a downwards trending support
line. And this is a downwards trending
resistance line. And so what those do is
those essentially make a channel and
they make it really easy to identify
what the market is doing. Now because
the market is always changing now a
clear kind of one is actually on a
bigger time frame right now. This is the
NASDAQ futures. So how you want to draw
a trend line and start one is you'll see
here we're looking at the big swings
here and then it makes a high here and
then it starts to just trend lower. Now
you're not going to know these right
away. It takes some time and you know it
usually takes at least two swings to be
able to draw that trend line before
knowing it could bounce off of it a
third time. And so I like to at least
wait for two swings to draw it off of.
And so here there's this big swing up
here and this swing right here. And so
for me I would take a drawing tool and
start it at the swing high here and then
draw it touching this next one. And then
so here you can see the market came up
here and it didn't quite touch this. If
if you put it to exactly the highs, but
so that's the big thing about any tool
or drawing tool you use in the market
with support or resistance, trend lines,
anything you use, take it with a grain
of salt. You can have some flexibility
in it. It's not going to be okay. Well,
it didn't touch my line exactly, so I'm
not going to it it didn't count, right?
Think of it more of like a zone. This is
a big thing I do and we'll talk about in
a minute with my support or resistance
levels is I don't think of it like one
line. I think of it as an area where
okay, well, the market will come up here
somewhere and reverse lower versus this,
you know, it it's a big line. I don't
wait for it to come exactly up here. So,
if it's coming up here, I'm thinking,
okay, well, it's close and you know, if
if a trade set up off that, then I would
take a trade off of it. And so once it
finishes, well then I'm going to adjust
based on that because I consider this to
be a pretty clear touch and a reversal.
And so going forwards again, I would
look at that and say, "Okay, well extend
this out and see what happens." And this
is where trend lines and everything
become very subjective is you can match
this either with the highs or you can
also drag it down here and say, "Well,
it kind of there's all these bodies
here." Well, if you do that, you can see
that this got a lot closer here and made
a lot more sense. And so that's where
drawing tools can be a little tricky or
drawing trend lines can be a little
tricky is it can be very subjective
because you can see here, well, once we
got down here and down here is what
pretty much was touching these ones as
well. And so that's kind of how trend
lines work. And so that's why we're
drawing them. My kind of rule of thumb
is take it with a grain of salt. It
doesn't count as a break of the trend
line if it, you know, breaks by one
candlestick and goes back in or it has a
wick that breaks above. A clean break of
a trend line is where the candlesticks
clearly break out here like this. And so
kind of on the flip side, what that can
look like, just to find you a quick
example here, here's another just moving
back in the chart a little bit. Here's
kind of a trend line right here I would
consider. And you can see here it's
clearly broken that. And so at that
point I would say hey I think that this
trend is over. The potential there means
that it's it could either go sideways or
it could reverse to the upside. And so
from that point you know you would use
whatever other factors you're using an
analysis like support zone here. I
already have drawn on the chart or just
looking at the big picture. Where are
the big swings uh in the market and kind
of what's been going on. So at that
point it looks like okay yeah it's kind
of bouncing and I would look for you
know kind of a move off of that. And so
when it comes to practically using trend
lines, they're going to be broken pretty
quickly a lot of the time. And a good
example was actually this morning in
gold where on a actually a one minute
chart here is it had a really nice
bottom here and a trend line up. And so
the market just followed this for a
while until it eventually broke. And so
you can have multiple types of trend
lines where they're really sharp here
and and just kind of very fastpaced or
like that bigger picture downtrend one
they were looking at and even gold
actually has one going on right now too
is zooming out to more of a bigger
picture 15-minute chart. As you can see
here, it's got this, you know, it made a
a larger swing high right here, kind of
a double top, and then it's had two
clear swings here, and then the third
one, I think, pretty clearly bounced off
of that. And so, another example here is
on the flip side, you can see on the
bottom end, I've drawn a swing off of
these two, and then there's this third
one right here. And so, it looks like
it's clearly starting to bounce there,
find some support. And so that's how you
can start to use these as clearly
predicting where the market could slow
down in reverse. Now one last one is it
I call it a spike in channel or a spike
in trend where uh a lot of times in a
beginning of a move the market right
here you can see it does a quick spike
where it just moves very rapidly in one
direction and then it starts to slow
down into more of a methodical trend.
Now, this one's still pretty tight here,
but you can have it essentially on the
flip side, too, on a on an uptrend where
it goes up and then it starts to go into
more of a healthier trend. The market
has a lot of different types of trends
where, you know, they're unhealthy moves
like this where they're likely to have a
pullback or consolidation at some point
or more healthier moves where, you know,
like this if we zoom out where, you
know, it it's slowly moving back and
forth. And that's more of a rangebound
move. And when it comes to trading
futures, I've always found it be to be
very important to stick to when there's
more volatility in the market because
trading in, you know, a choppy market.
This is the NASDAQ yesterday on a
5-minute chart. This is the whole day of
trading basically. And this is the first
kind of two hours. And you can see it
just sat here and did nothing. And so
that's times where you kind of want to
stay out and not watch the market too
much and save your money for a day where
you have more volatility like this where
there's more moves that are more
tradable. And so this is where
timeframes are really important to pay
attention to. You can trade whatever
time frame you want, but when it comes
to futures, I highly recommend sticking
to entering your trades on either a one
minute chart or a five-minut chart. And
then bigger picture, you can look at I
like to look at a 15-minute chart or a
30inut chart for kind of understanding
the broader picture of what the market's
doing, drawing these kind of bigger
swing moves. And that really helps you
understand the big picture of what's
going on because you can easily see,
okay, based on just the swings of the
market right here in gold that it's
pretty back and forth right now. It's
kind of in this downwards tightening
wedge that's going on. But just looking
at this and not really analyzing it too
much, you can think that, okay, well,
just based on what it's been doing, it's
kind of been going back and forth with
some moves in between. And so when it
makes this move, well, it's probably
likely to move back up because the
market likes to just repeat what it's
doing most of the time until obviously
the trend kind of shifts. But when it's
in this kind of back and forth mode,
going into a larger time frame to see
that and understand that is really
important because then you can go into a
one minute like this or a 5m minute and
enter your trades more accurately near
the lows of that swing and you know you
could enter in right here betting that
the market was going to go up, capture
that swing and you could get something
like four times your risk in your
profits. And so that's why time frames
are really important and especially day
trading and intraday trading because
when it comes to futures intraday margin
is very very powerful and the real
reason why I think it's good to trade
futures if you're trying to swing trade
futures I think there's other better
safer assets to do that. But when it
comes to day trading futures are really
really powerful because of the low
margin requirement that some brokers
have. And so that's what I use when it
comes to trading. I use a one minute and
a five minute to enter and a 15 and a 30
to analyze my charts. So let's talk
about the theory of supply and demand
first. And so if we're looking at just
like let's say a market of gold, well as
the price of gold is really low, there's
going to be a low supply of it because
there's not that many people wanting to
sell it. why would I sell, you know,
this gold bar that I think is valuable
for a really low amount of money? But as
the price gets really high, more and
more people are going to think, well,
hey, I want to sell my bar of gold
because I can get a lot of money for it
because the price of it is really high.
I'm getting a lot of value. But then on
the flip side for demand, well, if
something's really, really expensive,
like a bar of gold, I'm not going to
want it because I don't want to pay that
much money for something I think I can
get for a lesser value later. And so, as
time goes on, and as the price goes
down, demand actually increases. And so
you have imbalances where supply can be
really high but no one wants to actually
buy it because it's overvalued or times
where demand is really high but nobody
wants to sell it because they don't want
to sell it for dirt cheap. And so in the
middle here that's where you have more
of an equilibrium where buyers and
sellers meet. And so when it comes to
actually trading, what you can have is
and what you create is supply and demand
zones based on stuff that we'll talk
about in a minute of how you identify
these. But based on past observations,
you can start to create these and know
that okay, well, when the price comes
down to this demand zone, it's likely
that it's oversold, that the price is so
cheap that there's likely to be a high
demand, which will over time increase
the price because more and more people
want to buy it. And so the supply
actually starts to dry up. So, if
there's a finite amount of something,
the price is going to go up over time as
more and more people buy it and more and
more people want it. But eventually,
it's going to get to a point where it's
at a price where more people want to
start to sell it because they can get a
really high amount of money for it. And
so, the price will go down. And so,
quite often, you'll hit these extreme
areas and have strong moves off of them.
and then you'll get into that more
middle ground between the two where it
has that equilibrium and it'll have more
of a choppy market. And so this is why
when you look at a stock chart, it's
important to understand that these
extremes are the important part to pay
attention to because you'll likely have
the market bounce off these zones
quickly and like I said, chop around in
the middle and then it will once it
comes up to a level, you have that
potential to reverse off of it. And so
that's how you want to look at trading
these levels. And so this is how I like
to use them for trading is I like to
watch for key areas where I think that
the market might find a supply or demand
and it's likely to reverse off of the
supply and demand zone and then you can
capture a nice swing off of that. In
this trade right here, the market came
down to this demand zone down here and I
bought, went long and captured a move up
and made about $1,500 on this trade. And
then as it came up to where I thought
there was another supply zone, I got out
of the trade because it's likely that it
reverses off that zone and I wanted to
get out of my profitable trade and move
on with my day. Now, this is horizontal
supply and demand zones. What you can
actually have is trending supply and
demand zones where the market is moving
down slowly and it continues to move
lower over time. But what you get is it
starts to bounce off of supply and
demand zones as it creates those. And so
you can start to take trades as it tests
these levels. Another way to do this is
it can actually be created with more
trend lines. And so every time it comes
up to that trend line, you can think of
it as a supply zone. It's just more
horizontal. A good example of this is a
trade I took recently where the market
had a demand trend level down here that
I wanted to take a trade off of. And so
it bounced around, moved up higher, and
then sold off to that level to where I
thought, okay, it's likely that the
market starts to slow down here. Waited
for a setup that I like. a few key
patterns that I look for every time that
I'll talk about in a little while to
enter in, confirm the trade, and then I
waited for it to play out, and it
eventually played out, moving up to the
higher end of the range, and I was able
to get out for a clean $1,200 trade
pretty quickly. And so, that's how I use
supply and demand because it's so
powerful to simplify trading. There's so
many indicators and concepts when it
comes to trading and I always found the
best way is to focus on just one or two
things and supply and demand really
changed that around for me. So I want to
talk to you about the key concepts that
I use every time I draw supply and
demand zone so I know that it's actually
powerful and it's likely that the market
actually reverses off of it. Otherwise,
it's so easy going into our first
concept. It's so easy to draw supply
levels everywhere and not know which
ones are going to hold and which ones
are going to break. And so for me, the
first biggest thing is not looking at
those levels in the middle of the range.
I like to stick to then at an extreme of
that supply and demand in the market
versus being in that middle of that area
and you could have a chop and just not
have something that's worth taking a
trade. And so that's the first key
concept is stick to extremes in the
market. I always find that for my
trades, even though I have a, you know,
a three to fivestep checklist I look for
every time I enter into a trade, it
doesn't matter if everything on a one
minute chart is aligning up perfectly
and it looks like it's going to have a
great trade. if the big picture isn't
aligned and saying like, hey, yeah, I
think that we could bounce to the upside
or that we're at a extreme where the
overall price is likely to have a
snapback, then there's no trade. This is
the most important thing when it comes
to executing and confirming my trades is
things being at an extreme and also the
big picture being aligned with what I
think is going to happen. Now, when it
comes to drawing these zones, what I
like to do is I like to see at a minimum
multiple touches. So, in terms of here,
there's this swing right here and then
there's these two touches right here.
And so, what I did was I said, "Okay,
hey, I think, you know, when the market
was trending nearly where it is right
now with that bounce we just saw, I go
back multiple, this is me going back
almost a month in data to find this
level." And so I go based off of okay,
we have the extreme down here and then
we've also got a couple of bounces here.
It looks like we kind of had a head and
shoulders here, but essentially there's
some chop in here and some bounces. And
so that's I think okay, it's you know
why I draw a zone and then I'm just
going to drag it across here to where
essentially the current price is. And as
the market came down here, I said,
"Okay, I think it's likely we bounce off
of here." And then it gets a nice really
clean double bottom and then I go into a
smaller time frame and look to see if
there's a nice setup right here and I
can catch a big swing higher. And so the
reason why I draw zones instead of very
specific lines for my horizontal levels
is because it's a supply and demand
zone. You don't know where exactly it's
going to bounce. It's going to bounce
somewhere in this area. Every time the
market comes down and tests a level,
things are going to slightly change.
Maybe the market will come down here and
barely test it here because in this
instance, when it's coming down to this
level, well, there's some news out or
for some reason a lot of people want to
buy it now and it's going to bounce way
sooner or it pushes further down. people
are less interested in buying it until
it gets to an even deeper extreme and
then that imbalance happens and people
swoop in, pick it up quickly and then it
rockets up. And so that's why you can
see there's a big rocket in this case.
And so that leads into our next concept
is when there is a massive move off of a
level, I like to key into that as well
because if there is really aggressive
buying or selling, it means that a lot
of people came in in the buying side,
there was a lot of demand. And so it
makes it more likely that when it comes
back in the future, people are going to
want to buy it. or on the flip side, if
there's a big selling, it makes it more
likely that people are going to want to
sell when it comes up to this area. Now,
most of the time, I like to just look at
the last few days for a lot of my levels
because that's the most recent price
action, and it's more likely that
something's going to happen based off of
that. If you zoom really far out and you
have a level all the way from back here,
when the market touches that again
months later, I find that a lot of the
time something has changed at that
point. And if it comes all the way down
here, I'm going to look for that to
potentially break. Now, let's talk about
some keys of how do you know to the best
of your judgment? because you never
truly know and can never truly confirm
if a supply or demand level is going to
hold is it's how the market comes into
that level. And so you have multiple
trends where either you have a very
fastpaced extreme aggressive move or you
have a healthy trend with methodical
pullbacks where it sometimes even breaks
the trend, moves around, chops, touches
the zone and then continues to chop a
little bit. But essentially how I see it
is when the market has a very fast-paced
move like this, it's more likely to
bounce at a zone just like this move
right here. And the reason why is
because it's an unhealthy move. The
market when it just has an unhealthy
move in general, even if there isn't a
supply or demand zone, it needs some
kind of pullback to create that
equilibrium. And when it hits that
extreme of this supply and demand theory
graph, there's going to be so much
supply in the market. If we quickly go
back to the concept here, it's because
if it shoots down so fast, there's some
crazy momentum pushing it and pushing
and forcing price to be so cheap down
here. But at some point when it gets so
cheap, people are going to start buying
it and sellers are going to eventually
start to dry up and you will have what
is called a Vbottom. And so you have
that right here. In this case, it
actually did almost a double Vbottom
where it came down, spiked, supply kind
of push it down lower one more time, and
then as it hit here again, people came
in and said, "No, this is a amazing
price." And it rockets up from there.
And so this is how a volatile market
works because supply and demand is all
over the place and that is really really
good for trading when a a and for likely
that a level will hold. Now, sometimes
you'll have it to where it just blows
through a level, and those are easy to
avoid. And that's why one thing is,
we'll get to my checklist in a minute of
why you have a reasons that you look out
for to jump in and buy in an area like
this. You don't just blindly say, "Hey,
I'm going to put in a limit order down
here, a buy order that when this price
comes down here, if it does, I just want
to get long no matter what it looks like
because I think it's likely to go up."
Well, that's not always true because
supply can be so powerful that it blows
right through this level and you have to
look at the next level. And so those
unhealthy trends when they do start to
lose a little momentum, I find it's
likely that it reverses and those are
the best trades. Now, when a zone is
more likely to break is, if maybe we can
find a quick one here is this was a
pretty good zone right here. You know,
this was the zone I was watching for a
while. We had multiple touches up here.
You could even drag it down and take
this swing. This is a clear swing where
it came up to that zone, bounced off. We
had a lot of chop up here. It eventually
sold off. And when the market came up
here again, well, I'm looking at the big
picture. And so the big picture is we've
come down, sold off, there was a big
news that caused a spike. The whole time
after that news, the market was just
kind of chopping back and forth. And
well, pattern-wise, this is a this is a
bull flag right here. And if you look at
the lows, they're essentially getting
higher and higher. Every time after the
first couple times, the market would
make a push up here. The swing low would
get higher and higher. And what that
means is people are coming in and buying
the extremes that where it gets pushes
to the downside sooner and sooner. And
so as it starts to in my eyes has a
healthy move up here where there's moves
with ups and pullbacks and it starts to
kind of sit here and you know it kind of
sat here and chopped around for a while
and it sold off and then it comes up
here and starts to sit here again. To
me, that makes it way more likely that
it continues higher. And this is
actually one of the trades we looked at
a minute ago that I just quickly showed.
This is where that trend line of
trending supply and demand worked out as
well. You can also see as the moves move
up, it creates those with the swings.
And so this is the cleanest one right
here where it popped up, sold off a
little. And so you could say, well, this
is a micro supply level. Came back down
to here, broke that, hit another supply
level. It was kind of the highs at this
point. Big area where it's likely to
sell off, sold off. And then at this
point, you have multiple touches here to
where I drew this trend line. This was
actually before market opens where it
came up and it hit this demand trend
line and also hit this previous say
supply level that turned into a demand
level. So that's the interesting thing
as well is levels when they're broken
can flip. And so in this case, and this
happens all the time where you have a
high and then the market breaks that and
it comes back and tests that high. And
you can see this all over the market. If
you just zoom out and kind of look, you
can see here's another concept of it
happening where the market came up here,
put in a high, kind of sold off a little
bit, broke above that, and then if you
pretty much just draw these highs, it
came up, bounced off of it, and made an
attempt to keep going higher before the
market started selling off rest of this
day. Now, where you can get in trouble
is overanalyzing. And that's why I like
to stick to where it's just super clear
and really obvious what's going on and
staying out of insanely choppy times
like this. The market the last couple
days here you can see these are the
opening days and then this is kind of
the overnight movement. Every day here
the the NASDAQ here has pretty much just
done nothing. There's times in the
market where you'll have movements that
are just terrible for trading. Every
strategy has market conditions that are
crappy. My strategy is more of a
reversal strategy of taking trades off
of either big trend lines and looking
for a move down or off of, you know,
good support lines and looking for moves
up off of those. But any time that the
market is just sitting here chopping
like this and you can even go to a one
minute chart. Today had some good
movement for the first time. But if I
zoom in on this day, you can see it's
just back and forth. If you zoom in, it
looks like maybe there's some good
movement. But big picture again, there's
really really little movement to
capture. Or continuation markets are
terrible when the market is in more of a
rangebound or reversal volatile market.
And so that's why it's really important
for you to understand what markets are
good to trade in and what aren't. And
the biggest one again is choppy markets
and just learning to understand and
read, okay, well, when is there a big
movement and volatility? That's when you
want to start paying attention and
looking for potential trades. It doesn't
have to be necessarily looking for
reversals. It could be looking for
continuations if you think the trend is
really strong. Again, that's why you
look at the big picture and say, "Okay,
what do I think is happening?" And if we
look at and analyze this, well, the
market was in a big downtrend and then
it started to have this support level.
Well, I think when it breaks this
support level, it's had all this
consolidation, which is really healthy
for the market. And so, once it breaks,
it's very likely to have a large move in
that direction because it's broken this
support level. It's not overextended.
it's unlikely to fake lower and continue
higher because also looking to the left
side of the chart, there isn't great
support levels to look at. It had a kind
of a pretty strong trend up. And so big
picture, this trend could be reversing
and having a pullback before, you know,
it it does whatever it's going to do
next. And that's where if you, you know,
wondered what this would be doing next
on a bigger picture, you could zoom out
even more to, let's say, like a
60-minute chart or even a daily chart.
And that's where, you know, ignore all
the random little drawing time frames
because those are incorrect. We're on a
daily chart right now. But, you know,
looking at a daily chart, this is where
I would think, okay, we're in a clear
big uptrend. You know, we might be
having a bit of a pullback here, but I'm
assuming we're in an uptrend until we
have a clear like pullback and a double
top and, you know, something starting to
fail here. And that's where time frames
are really important to understand of
just because on a daily chart right here
the NASDAQ is in an uptrend doesn't mean
that if I go to a you know a 5minut
chart or a one minute chart I'm not
going to be looking for a short on a
shorter period time frame. You can still
be looking for shorts and longs. It just
m depends on what time frame you're
looking at and what those time frames
are telling you about the market. And so
what's really important and helpful is
understanding just basic candlestick
patterns. What these will do for you is
once you kind of understand how to read
markets, you don't really need these,
but it's a good cheat sheet when you're
first starting because if we look at
this, like here is a descending triangle
and it's basically saying, okay, the
market has a horizontal support with a
downwards trend line and the trend into
it was a downtrend. And so once it
breaks this to the downside, this
support, it's saying it's likely to
continue lower. And if we look at our
NASDAQ chart, well, you can see we
pretty much had a downwards descending
triangle right here where it had that
support level and then a downwards trend
line. And once it broke that, it had a
really big move lower. And so that's a
really good way to use these and match
them up with what's going on to help you
understand when you're starting to learn
these as a beginner. And so when it
comes to actual candlestick patterns as
well, these can really help you break
down some smaller patterns of what could
potentially be happening right at these
inflection points. Now these are all
reversal patterns. Once you kind of
understand what they mean is it really
makes a lot of sense. And so for
instance here, this one, it's a V
reversal because you have a trend coming
down quickly and then you have a hammer
candlestick pattern where the market
essentially just goes like this in that
one candlestick and then big picture it
continues higher. This candlestick
pattern essentially on a smaller time
frame, what I'm drawing here is it
essentially just makes a double top and
a double top is a larger bigger picture
structure reversal pattern. And these
ones right here is they are a momentum
switch where the market is going down in
this case really methodically and start
to slow down and you have a massive
switch in momentum. And so going through
this will really help you understand how
these can work. And another one is
essentially consolidation where the
market either here it has it in a form
of just a dogee or here it has it in the
form of multiple candlesticks where it
has a downtrend. It starts to just go
sideways and then it moves up. And so
this is also something you can get if
you get that 90-day trader road map.
It'll just be emailed to you as well.
And it's really something that is I
think really helpful for understanding
candlestick patterns. Now, let's jump
into the top six candlestick patterns
I've used over the years. These are
common candlestick patterns that you
will see that based on their structure
and the market psychology of what the
data is showing you commonly will play
out in a specific manner. Now, the first
one of these candlestick patterns is
called the engulfing candlestick
pattern. It's just a two candlestick
pattern, but what it signifies is that
it's a reversal pattern where the chart
is coming down. And if you see this
pattern, it will signify that it's
likely that the price reverses to the
upside. The idea of how this works is
you have a bearish candlestick that is
engulfed by a bullish candlestick right
after it where the open of this
candlestick is lower than the low of the
previous candlestick and the close of it
is higher than the high of the bearish
candlestick. The whole idea is it is a
massive reversal happening where it
completely blows out the previous
candlestick. And this can happen on the
flip side for the bearish version too
where a smaller bullish candlestick is
engulfed by a big bearish candlestick.
And again, the idea is that it's a
reversal candlestick and likely the
market is going to reverse after this.
And this is a great confirmation for an
entry just like the trades I showed
earlier. But again, you don't want to
just blindly be using it by itself. The
next one of these patterns is called a
pin bar candlestick. This is where the
important of wicks comes into play. What
this can help us do is it's another
reversal candlestick pattern. But the
idea is that you have a big bullish
candlestick followed by what's called
this reversal candlestick. This large
wick is showing us that the price tried
to continue higher and was rejected.
It's showing you a flip in the momentum
of the market that this is representing.
the price was previously moving higher
and a topping pattern is going to flip
the price of the market and this
candlestick here is showing that and
followed by it to complete this pattern
is a nice bearish reversal candlestick
after this. The idea is that this is
going to reverse lower and it's a
confirmation that you can use to enter
into a trade. Same thing goes for the
bullish version where it's coming down
reversing in a big way and it's
indicating that the market could
continue higher reversing that trend
that it was in. This is how you can
start to read the market like a book.
You can start to use these patterns and
slowly build upon them, connecting them
so you can eventually read a whole stock
chart clearly. This next candlestick
pattern is called a threeline strike
pattern. What it's showing you is there
is a clean methodical uptrend in the
market and then it is broken and
reversed very rapidly by this huge
engulfing candlestick that engulfs
multiple of the candlesticks before it.
It shows you a massive switch in
momentum and a massive increase in
momentum in the other direction. And so
how you can use this is again bullish or
bearish side is that the market is
switching from a slow methodical move
lower to a rapid move higher. Buyers are
really stepping in wanting to buy at
this level which is likely to continue
to push the market higher after this
pattern. Again, these patterns are super
powerful, but you have to stack them
with other indicators now that we can
start to get into some larger patterns.
And a flag pattern is a key pattern that
will help us understand how to read
dogeis. And so, how this pattern works
is it's a continuation pattern. The idea
is the market moves up and goes
sideways. It essentially creates a flag.
The idea with this is the market's had a
really strong move higher and it's now
just taking a breather. It's coming to a
point where it just needs to catch its
breath. It's a little overextended. And
this pattern often signifies a
continuation that it could continue
higher. That this momentum that it had
before is just taking a pause and it's
going to come back in and push the
market higher. But what will often
happen is you'll start to see dogeis
here when it flags out. And dogeis are
okay if there's a couple of them, but
once there becomes too many, you can
start to get trapped. If we flip over to
the bearish version here, it's the same
thing to the flip side where we have a
strong momentum to the downside, but
then it starts to go sideways. And the
key to knowing if this is really going
to continue or it could do what I call a
failed breakout where it attempts to
break lower and the market actually
reverses trapping people and making this
pattern cause a false signal is when you
start to get a lot of dogeis stacking
up. When you start to see the market
just sit there for too long, that's when
the momentum has really just dried up
and it's not taking a brief break. The
idea with this pattern is it has a large
momentum move and it just takes a quick
break before it continues higher. If it
starts to take too long of a break like
this, that's when you want to stay out.
That's when the dogeis can really start
to give you some insight that there is
too much indecision in the market and
it's likely to not have a clear move in
either direction that is easy to trade
and you should stay out of the market. I
used to fall for this all the time
myself. This pattern right here looks
really clean, right? But this can easily
turn into what I call a failed breakout
where the market pushes lower and then
immediately flips on you reversing
higher. There's one key missing step
that is really good to know to tell the
difference between if it's actually
going to break out or do a fake out. And
we're almost to where we can talk about
that, but I want to first talk about a
few big picture candlestick patterns
that are really going to tie this all
together for you. The first one of those
is a pullback pattern. This is a super
simple market structure pattern, but
it'll start to connect some of these
dots for you. The whole idea with this
is here's the bearish version, which
means the market's going to reverse is
the market's coming up in a nice solid
trend higher. It pulls back and then it
pushes one more time up. But then what
happens is you'll notice we get an
engulfing candlestick pattern right
here. And what that signals is it's
putting in a lower high right here. This
swing, if you kind of just think about
it like a line chart now, is the market
made a high here, pulled back, made one
more high here, and now is pushing
lower. That high is lower than this one.
And in the big picture structure idea of
the market, that is a big reversal
signal. If you couple it with this
engulfing candlestick pattern, this
starts to become a powerful signal. As
soon as this engulfing candlestick
pattern here is formed, you can use that
as a confirmation to enter in on a trade
with the idea that the market is going
to push lower based off of that. Same
thing goes for the bullish side. But you
can see on the flip side, same thing,
but you could have a different
candlestick pattern, making this, you
know, you can even call it a double
bottom. This is how you start to look at
candlesticks and create larger picture
structures in the market that can signal
key areas that you want to pay attention
to. So, you can start to see this
pattern and the flag pattern are very
similar in a lot of ways. How do you
know when a pattern is going to either
continue or when it's going to fake you
out in the opposite direction in
reverse? Which is why in a minute we're
going to go over how do you know when
it's actually the right time to jump
into a trade versus when it's important
to stay out so you don't actually get
trapped and lose money. Now, before we
go further, if you want a downloadable
guide that goes through all of these
candlestick patterns, I've created a
free 14page PDF that you can download
for free in the description of this
video, and it will go into way more
patterns with way more detail that I
highly recommend you get. You can
download it in the description of this
video or via this QR code. Now, the last
one of these is called the head and
shoulders pattern. It's a big key
reversal pattern, but again, it's really
powerful when you couple it with the
indicators that really confirm whether
an area is worth taking a trade or not.
The whole idea of how this works is it's
looking at the big picture structure of
the market. It's essentially looking at
the swings of the market where it's
making a in an uptrend. It's making
higher highs and higher lows
consistently and then all of a sudden it
switches to making lower lows and then
lower highs. What you'll start to notice
about these patterns is that they're
very simple. You do not need complex
patterns to understand what the market
is doing. And keys with this head and
shoulders pattern is on the bullish side
where this is going to signal, you know,
we're going to make a reversal to the
upside. This key is you want this final
extreme low that it makes to be strong
and then it to reverse quickly.
Essentially, it's showing you the market
got overextended, accelerated to this
side, and then buyers came in in a big
way and pushed it to the upside. This
final pullback here and really adding
this pullback pattern that we talked
about earlier, essentially what it's
doing is it's showing you, it's giving
you the confirmation of, okay, is this
going to just continue lower? Because,
well, it could just continue making
lower lows and lower highs here. But
once it creates this bottom here and
really starts to form this candle and
this candle, that's when you can
confidently say that okay, it's starting
to shift. And that's how you use these
patterns to understand what the market
is going to do. Now, I want to jump into
the personalities of these major
markets. What I trade the most is the
NASDAQ futures, the S&P 500 futures,
gold futures, and oil futures. And these
all four have different personalities
and how they react to a lot of these
patterns that we've gone over. they will
react differently to them, respect them
in a different way, which makes it
really important to actually practically
trading these because when it comes to,
you know, looking at a move like this on
gold here, I'm going to approach it
differently than a move like that on the
ES or the NASDAQ. And so, first I want
to go over the ES futures. And the major
things that I think about it is I think
one, it's great for beginners because
it's very methodical and a lot more
predictable. I think the moves in the
S&P 500 futures are a lot more solid. It
doesn't have as many fake outs in one
direction. It's not likely to spike one
way and then go the other as often. You
know, take everything with a grain of
salt. Of course, you can have, you know,
a spike like this and then a reversal,
but it's not going to be as volatile as
something like the NASDAQ. And so the
NASDAQ, one thing about it is it's more
volatile compared to the ES. If you look
at the NASDAQ in the first 30 minutes
here, or let's just say an hour is it
was pretty volatile. And if we look at
the ES in the first hour, just to adjust
here, it was more volatile, but it
wasn't as all over the place. The moves
were a little different. And what this
shows me is that it helps me realize,
and I think as a beginning trader, it if
you're watching ES here, instead, you
will realize that, okay, it's it's more
choppy. It's back and forth. The
market's not really sure what it wants
to do. And then when it has more of a
breakout in one direction, you can see
that okay, that is a stronger move and
you can make a decision if you think
that's an actual solid breakout or it's
a failed breakout versus the NASDAQ was
having moves all over the place very
fast. These candlesticks right here are
huge and that can be a lot harder to
trade in. Now, obviously the NASDAQ and
the ES are very correlated most of the
time. Sometimes you'll have the ES where
it's more choppy and the NASDAQ is more
movement. And so that's mainly the only
main difference between the two in terms
of direction. The NASDAQ could be doing
something like it's selling off because
it's, you know, more tech focused where
the S&P 500 futures could be actually
moving up or just kind of going
sideways. And I think if you're looking
to trade just one, which I think is the
better way to start out because trying
to look at both can be a little
confusing. I would stick to the ES
futures because they are more likely to
not fake you out and give you a better
directional movement. Now, when it comes
to respecting trend lines and levels, I
have found that the NASDAQ and the S&P
500 futures will sometimes break a trend
line after the move has already started.
So, what I mean by that is let's say we
have a trend line right here. Well, I
will sometimes see that if we're coming
down to a support level here, the entry
to jump in the trade is before the
signal of it breaking the downtrend.
Now, I don't always do this. I would say
if you're a beginner, don't do that.
Wait until it breaks a downtrend clearly
because again, that's always a very
obvious confirmation. But there's times
where the market can move really fast
and it makes sense to jump in before it
actually breaks that downtrend. But in
that case, I'm using it with idea that I
think based on what I'm seeing, it's
going to break that downtrend. Now, when
it comes to gold is I have noticed that
gold is way more methodical and respects
its trend lines more than the S&P 500
future and then the NASDAQ. You know, it
had this trend line right here. And I
would not take a trade to the long side,
big picture, until it broke this
downtrend. Now, on a smaller time frame,
you totally could jump in on a long here
like this guy because the idea is, well,
if you jump in long here, let's say on
this pullback, you're going to be in the
profit before it hits where it likely
reverses here. But like for this, if you
were on a trade long right here, betting
that the market was going to go up and
you were making money as this goes up,
as soon as this breaks this trend line,
I'm going to get out of the trade
because likely with gold that it's going
to either start going sideways or go
down or, you know, maybe it'll start
continue going up, but the the trend is
over that I want to be following. Same
thing down here is it had a really
strong trend this morning uh after that
kind of move and then once it broke that
my thought was okay well it might
reverse or it might go sideways and you
know again looking at other factors I
didn't actually think that this was
going to go up cuz you can see the
bigger picture is coming into play and
pushing this thing down. Also with gold
I have found that a lot of the time
entering in on a fiveminut chart is
actually better than a one minute chart.
Now, the only time I do just because
again it's more methodical and slow
moving now when it has some volatility
like it had this morning like this move
right here and you would know that the
volatility is happening because these
candlesticks here are showing you that
the volatility is happening and then so
when it starts to bounce here I would
jump in somewhere right here on this
pullback and bet the market was going to
go up because it's had that volatility
and I can get a trade signal based on
that. And same thing here, but you know,
for other reasons I'm not going to jump
into too much, I would think jumping in
there on a 1 minute or 5 minute would
make sense. And so, kind of on that
note, going back to the ES and the
NASDAQ, though, I think you can trade
both. Again, it some of that is always
going to be personal preference. A one
minute chart is always going to be more
fast-paced, more intense, and more
likely to trigger your impulses and and
have you, you know, jump in on a trade
when maybe you shouldn't yet. Where a 5
minute is always going to have slower,
more methodical, stronger signals. But I
think you can kind of do both. What I
like to do is I like to do a one minute
for generally my, you know, I like to
trade and look for reversals in kind of
the first 30 minutes. And I like to use
a one minute for that because a five
minute is a little too slow for a lot of
the the whips saws and movements that
happen in that time period. Now the last
one here is oil futures and oil is a lot
trickier than these other markets I
think. Now, I probably take a trade in
oil once every few weeks or even months
because a lot of the time is it's very
kind of choppy and back and forth and
then it can have just a big move out of
nowhere. And what that's from is it's
it's because it's very newsdriven is you
can see if we go on a one minute chart
here looking at this you can see that
it's moving almost nothing is because of
how the candlesticks look here. It's
even gapping between each one of these
lines is a tick, which is, you know, the
smallest movement a futures market can
have. And so oil just based on these
candles, you can see that it just looks
super super choppy and it's just not
moving at all really today. And so even
on a 5minute, you can see that okay,
well, it's it's still pretty choppy.
It's having some kind of methodical
moves, but most of the time, you know,
it's just not really doing much. Now, if
I look at a one minute chart, yesterday
it did have a decent little spike lower.
Now, actually, I think it's set up on a
5minute chart better. And so, that's
where, you know, sometimes a 5minut is a
little better. And it doesn't mean just
because on a on a 1 minute it's choppy.
It doesn't necessarily mean it's bad to
take a trade on a 5minut. But you can
see here it had a little spike lower,
came to actually support level, and then
started to bounce. And you could have
kind of caught this initial spike and
then maybe this trend higher. But it's a
lot trickier and I very rarely take
trades in it because they don't set up
very often. But when they do, they're
good trades. That's why I like to watch
it and keep track because it can still
have really good moves. I figured out
the simplest scalping strategy that
turns losing traders into profitable
ones. Not only has this strategy worked
for me, but it's also worked for other
traders who have tried it out and they
have turned into being consistent over
the long run. I've compiled a ton of
real trade examples, so by the end of
this video, you will know exactly how to
execute this strategy just like these
other profitable traders. To give you a
super quick overview before we dive into
the nuts and bolts of how you can
consistently execute this pattern
yourself every day, all I do is when the
US market opens, I look at the first 30
to 60 minutes. All I'm looking for is a
clean support and resistance level and
then I look for a few key patterns. For
example, right here there's a nice
double top. All I do then is I see a
nice candlestick pattern and then I
enter in on a trade short betting that
the market is going to go down and then
from there I let the market play out.
I've noticed over time that the market
consistently has a reversal in the first
30 to 60 minutes of a trading day. And
so what this strategy does is it allows
you to take advantage of that reversal.
And then coupling that with looking for
key areas of resistance or support,
you're able to essentially pingpong the
market between those levels, capturing a
big potential profit for a smaller
amount of risk. And this is all I do
every day. This is the only thing I look
for every single day. And it allows my
trading to be super simple and
straightforward so that you can go into
every day with a plan and know how to
execute it instead of what I did before
when I was unprofitable. I was trying to
match what the market was doing and that
just was not profitable. And I know from
teaching a ton of people how to do this,
that's the exact same way they feel as
well. Let me walk you through how I
entered and found this trade. And so
initially what I'm seeing is you can see
that the market had a nice methodical
trend up here and then this bearishness
right here showed me that okay
something's changed. We've broken this
uptrend. That's a massive thing that I
like to look for. And then also this big
trend line right here is drawn from a
bigger picture where on a 15 or 5 minute
I can see that the market consistently
is coming up to this level. It comes up
here again it's likely to continue
lower. Obviously, if I see the threeline
strike pattern that I like to see and a
couple of other factors and so seeing
that it had this big bearishness here,
that was a great confirmation to say,
okay, the momentum in this market is
switching. You always want to take that
into account. We came down here, had a
little bit of a bounce, showed, you
know, some momentum. Essentially, you
could even say this is a 50% pullback
from this area. You can see it's
literally in the middle of that box. The
market likes to do pullbacks like that
that are literally halfway of the move
it just had. And so it moved down this
far. It pulled back halfway. That's what
this little spike here is. And then it
sold off. And for me, this isn't a super
picture perfect and really nice looking
threeline strike pattern. But for me, I
saw, you know, okay, there's some
movement up here. there's this big
attempt to go higher and then, you know,
it's essentially in this little mini
channel and then this big candlestick
here, especially with the fact that it
wicks higher right here, this little
wick right here. It's it's essentially
like a micro double top and then I get
in, you know, I I actually got in down
here a little bit because it was moving
pretty quickly, but the signal there is
at the candlestick close right there.
And so that's what I used to jump in on
this and then of course put the stop up
here. doesn't need to go all the way up
here above this trend line. You know,
what we're trying to do is risk a tight
amount and then have the big picture
potential for the market to really start
moving in our favor. And so, in this
trade, I think I'm risking like $500.
But, you know, that's why you can use
this kind of in any account size. You
can scale it up because again, trading
super scalable. You just use and find
one pattern that works and then increase
the money. You don't need to try and
find more patterns to make more trades.
That's what kind of kept me from being
profitable initially. And so you'll see
here actually once the market
essentially made a pullback here right
here and then moved down. I moved my
stop loss to break even because I want
to kind of tighten up the trade and get
out if it's going to pull back on me.
You know, sometimes the market's just
going to be choppy and all over the
place. I don't want to trade in that. I
want to be in trades and I've noticed
these trades will work out pretty
cleanly in your favor if they're going
to work out. And so from there, you
know, it starts moving down pretty
quickly. I'm trying to see, okay, is
there this downtrend line that I can
kind of expect the market to pull back
to. And again, that's kind of thinking
about, okay, how am I managing this? You
know, as you are trading, you want to be
thinking what to do next based on logic,
not okay, I'm up, you know, almost
$3,000.
Uh, you know, I'm really nervous. This
is a lot of money. I need to get out. Or
what if this keeps going? I could be up
5,000, 10,000. Right? You can't let your
emotions kind of control what you do.
You need to have a logical plan to trade
with. And so once this kind of got
rocketing in one direction, it gets
really far away from the trend line. And
I don't want to hold through a pullback.
You know, at this point, that's a big
pullback to hold through for it breaking
that trend line. And so I start using
kind of more of a tighter trailing
stop-loss with kind of previous
candlestick highs. And you can also see
there is this blue box down here. That's
a support level. And so big picture,
I've looked at, okay, well, the market's
already bounced here a couple times. If
we come down here again, I'm going to
expect that we're going to bounce or
slow down. And this is a really fastm
moving, unhealthy move, which is great
to be in if you're in it, but it's
likely to snap back at some point. And I
want to be out when it's going to snap
back. And so that's why I have kind of a
tighter trailing stop-loss. And you can
see it's starting to snap back a little
bit. And I want to give it a little
wiggle room because, you know, these
things can break through a support level
and keep going lower. But in this case,
it kind of starts to chop here. It makes
a double bottom and it essentially
knocks me out here. But I get, you know,
about $3,500, $3,200 worth of profit.
So, now that you have a good
understanding of what I look for every
trade, I want to zoom through a couple
more trade entries so you can get this
repetition down. Because at the end of
the day, trading is very repetitive, but
it's all slightly different. Every trade
entry has something slightly different
about it. There's going to be something
different to learn and take away from
every different trade entry. So, when
you try and do this yourself, you have
that pattern recognition in your mind.
We're going to jump into one more pretty
in-depth walkthrough so you really have
a good understanding of the trade
entries. And then also I'm going to show
you a couple trades of doing this on a
small account. You can do this starting
with $50 to $100. I had a whole
challenge where I took $50 and turned it
into over $3,000 using this strategy.
And now, let me kind of give you a deep
dive into the checklist I use for each
one of these trade entries and how to
know why the fair value gap is going to
really reverse versus, you know, before
a lot of people will try and see that
fair value gap and kind of buy here
looking for it to go long. And sometimes
that'll happen and I'll avoid those
trades because of a few key factors. You
need just the basics of this fair value
gap to be popping off. And the biggest
thing is having a bunch of them compared
to the trade today I took. That'll
really increase your confidence because
when the market whips up that high that
fast, it's really likely to give it back
up because of remember that imbalance in
the market. That's what really makes
this so powerful and allows you to when
you trade to enter in and risk a smaller
amount or have a good riskreward ratio
to where you can be risking, you know,
$100, $1,000, doesn't matter what your
size is, but you're going for three
times your risk. That's a massive key
when it comes to trading. For me, I have
found that's way easier to be successful
at. And so, kind of the first thing is
you want those fair value gap
indicators. And then second is coming up
to this resistance zone. You have to
have a key level to be trading these off
of. You do not want to be just trading
them randomly. Here's a clean example of
really just right before this trade
happened is where there's this is big
indicator of overextension, right? But
you can see there is if we kind of zoom
out, there's not really a good clean
level. There's kind of something here,
but if you really zoom out, that's
middle of the range. The good extreme
levels down here. I'm not going to go
over how to draw key levels in this
video. I'll link a video up here on how
to do that properly, but that is why and
a reason why you want to stay from away
from something like this because there
isn't a good zone to reverse off of. You
need to be waiting for there to be a
really clean zone like this. and then
going into a one minute chart because I
like to trade on a one minute chart
right when the market opens. I'll take a
five minute entry a little later
sometimes or if the market's a little
slower, but in this case I took it on a
1 minute because it made a really nice
setup. Now another huge factor in this
trade is there was timing. I have three
kind of timing windows I look for and
the window this one aligned up was 30
minutes after the market opens. I
constantly see reversals happen at that
time. And so this is a another catalyst
on what makes this a really good setup.
And then kind of the final thing is you
know you have this uptrend that's broken
but a big thing is looking at the
structure of the highs and the lows. the
swings. And so here, you know, in an
uptrend, it's making higher highs and
higher lows. And so I need to see that
stop and it make a lower high. This is a
massive key factor here. And so from
that point, that's when I look to jump
in the trade. Sometimes I'll look and
say, okay, I like a five minute better,
but the five minute kind of just chopped
here pretty good, too. So when I was
actually trading this, this took a long
time to get going. On a five minute, it
looks pretty simple. But on a one
minute, it took about 20 30 minutes to
get going. And when I was trading larger
than normal size, I put $1,400 of risk
on this trade, my kind of normal large
size is a,000. And because this was such
a good setup, I did a little extra
because of how confident I was in it.
And so it makes just the waiting even
that much worse. And so eventually
they'll punch down here, move to break
even, and set a limit order here at two
times my risk. Essentially, a good
target is the bottom of the main move.
That's the easy money if you ask me. And
then after that, my thought is, okay, I
will trail this thing and let it keep
going if it's going to keep going. But
if it has a big pullback like it just
did, I'm going to get out and call it a
day. And so the first thing of course is
using those two indicators is to see
that we're coming up into a key
resistance zone. Again, you can draw
these yourself based on that other video
or I do have an indicator that does it
pretty well automatically. And the
second thing, of course, is this move
was overextended based on the other
overextension indicator. So you have
those two keys showing up showing you
that this has a high probability to
reverse. That is the biggest confidence
booster when it comes to trade. And this
is what honestly helps me focus on the
process as much as possible is always
making sure that you have those two keys
in place before you even sit down and
consider taking a trade. It helps you
just avoid all the noise when it comes
to trading. And so that's the honestly
the first thing in the checklist is
having a key reversal zone and having an
overextension indicator signal come up.
The next thing is having a key reversal
pattern. What I like to do is look for
either a double top or a head and
shoulders or even in this case it did
essentially a fail breakout here where
it broke above the previous extreme
high. got a lot of people in excited,
thinking it was going to go higher and
then it reversed. And so this
candlestick right here gave me a ton of
confidence. And then the final
confirmation was that it had this little
pullback here and then pushed lower with
this big candlestick confirming a lot of
momentum to the downside. And that is
where I essentially entered in on my
trade and then used my riskreward
calculator tool here to put my stop loss
up here and target a certain amount of
risk. You want to try and keep your risk
the same every time. And then as this
moves in my favor, you know, I slowly
move my stop losses down. And usually
the initial target I have for these
trades is if it gives back up that
overextended move. But you always want
to try and let it run a little bit more
just in case it's going to keep going
farther. So, this trade right here had a
pretty big spike down and I closed out
right here for pretty much $2,000 in
under 15 minutes in the morning. Here's
another example. And this is on the flip
side looking for a long. You can see
clearly I'm looking at a support level
here where the market's bounced once,
twice. There was probably another bounce
here before on the previous area in the
chart that I was looking at. And so I'm
already looking for the big picture of
the market to come down here and bounce.
And to accurately enter and confirm that
the market's going to bounce here is I
looked for the market to make a
essentially it slowed down here and then
it had a strong bullish candlestick here
form and I got in essentially as it was
about to finish closing. I got in a
couple seconds earlier, but I
essentially got in as it created that
threeline strike pattern. And you can
see here, it was actually a candlestick
after the bottom here. It wasn't right
away, but it was still showing me that
switch in momentum, and it gave me an
accurate entry to enter in at the bottom
of the swing, have a tighter stop-loss,
and then capture the reversal back
higher. And so this is super super
powerful for capturing trades like this.
You know, every trade is going to go
slightly different. We're going to go
over that massive one here in a minute,
but this is still a really nice trade to
capture, you know, $4 $500 worth of
profit. Again, just trading 60 minutes
in the morning. And so at that point,
you know, the market kind of slowed
down. I said, "Okay, I want to get out
if it breaks lower because it could just
give that swing back up." And that's
where I kind of got out at about $400
and moved on with my day. Now, this is a
good example of a trade on a small
account. I'm kind of doing a small
account challenge right now. And this is
on a small account. And so, I'm risking
$100 here, betting that the market is
going to reverse off of this resistance
level that I've drawn. And then, you
know, betting it to go probably kind of
down here. And we'll talk about targets
and why that's a good target later. But
if it gets down there, that's a good
two, three times my risk. And on a small
account risking $100, that is a nice
profit. And so the first thing that I'm
looking for obviously is that it comes
up to that level first, right? That is
the number one key thing to make
reversal trading work is the patience to
just wait for the market to come to an
extreme and key level. You can even see
the market came here and reversed off of
this little area right here. You can
say, "Well, you know, it bounced here.
It bounced here. It bounced here. And so
maybe it bounces here. Maybe I should
have got that. You know, maybe you even
look at hindsight and say, "Oh, I'll try
and get that next time." But those don't
work very often, and they're more likely
to cause you to lose money in the long
run. It's better to just sit out, kill
that noise, and wait for the market to
come to these extremes. And then when
it's oversold or overbought in this
case, you can capture on that strong
reversal to the downside. And so, the
first key that I like to use is after
it's kind of hit that level, again, you
can see it's not quite in my zone, but
again, it's so close, it's good enough.
The first thing is making sure that
uptrend is broken. Because when you're
counter trend trading, you don't want to
go against a trend because, you know, it
might come up to a level here, but it's
in an uptrend and it's just going to
keep going, right? We don't know. These
these levels aren't going to hold every
time. It's not just blindly sell or buy
at these levels. And so that's kind of
why I have this uptrend here is you can
see that we had strong bullish
candlesticks here and then it it kind of
started to break is it had a dogey here.
It had a bearish candle here and then it
made kind of another push higher. And so
for me that's good enough to say, hey,
yeah, this strong kind of micro trend
right here is broken. And you can see
the market's kind of being quick with
its reversals. And so I'm okay with
thinking that that's a a good enough
trend break. Certain kind of trends,
they'll need something else. But in this
case, for this kind of very one
directional unhealthy trend, it's good
in terms of clearing that kind of need
for a reversal break. And so after that,
my next key that I like to look for is
kind of a reversal pattern or reversal
candlestick pattern. And so in this
case, the market started to show some
weakness here with this kind of dogee
here and this kind of red bar and it
broke that uptrend and then it made
these two candlesticks here, these
bullish candlesticks breaking this
previous high. This high right here
became a new one. And for me that said,
okay, it's still going higher. But as
soon as this big bearish candlestick
form right here, this big red one, that
to me is showing it almost made a a
micro failed breakout. It made that kind
of trap where it attempted to make a new
high and it it did it made a a new high
but barely at all. You know, it didn't
make much before this big bearish
candlestick came in. And so, if I kind
of zoom back in the recording and kind
of show you that in real time right now,
to speed this up a little, once this
candlestick finishes forming, I think
that's a a good signal for me. And I
want to get in right there at the low of
that candle. So my thought is, okay, I
want to get in when it kind of breaks
the low of this candle because to me
that's a strong enough signal that it's
likely going to reverse there. And so
you can see initially it kind of starts
to go against me and doesn't look great
initially, but you know that's where
when things reverse sometimes they take
a little while. The market won't always
just reverse on a dime. A lot of times
it'll come up like it did, kind of start
to settle down and slow and lose some of
that momentum and strength and then
it'll give it back up and start going.
And so that's what I'm kind of looking
for. And so for once I entered in there,
I moved my stop above this high because
the whole idea is if it comes up here
and knocks me out, you know, I'm looking
for that kind of quick reversal to fail.
And I think if it comes up here, comes
back down and and keeps going higher, I
think that's a stronger uptrend. It's
had a healthy pullback if it does that
and then it keeps going higher and you
know I I want to get out. The idea is
with trading is you take your stabs,
they either work out really quickly and
really well right away or they just
don't work out and you move on. If
you're trying to force a trade in
conditions where it's just not great and
not working out, you're going to lose
money if you try and enter in the market
over and over.
And a lot of the times when the market
has a big move like this, kind of like
we were talking about earlier that it's
a big area where the market velocity off
that area was really big. It's more
likely that when the market comes back
down there, it's going to find a bounce
and it's going to find some buyers and
support. And this trade right here is
going to dry up and slow down. And I
want to capture my profits here because
I'm getting, you know, about two two and
a half times my risk on this trade. And
that is a great trade to just
consistently make money and grow your
trading account. And again, that's what
you want to start out with. You don't
want to be trying to get home runs, make
a ton of money. Make your small account
grow over time. And then this, you can
10x this size. I have trades on my
channel where this trade would be
$2,000. And it's the exact same setup.
And so actually at that point you can
see I had my stop loss down there
because I was managing it pretty tight
because we got down to this area and it
closed out there and it actually started
to reverse and you can see it started to
reverse off that level. So now that
we've mainly focused and you have a good
understanding of entries, what you need
to learn now is how to manage the
trades. I have a couple different styles
of how I manage them and you'll start to
understand them throughout this section.
It can either be going for a fixed
profit target or managing the trade
fluidly. This is really important to get
down and understand because the entries
are the most important part, but being
able to maximize how much you're getting
from every trade is very important for
your long-term profitability. And so
essentially at this point, this is where
I'm thinking, okay, I want to see a
large candlestick here form because
that's going to help me with step three
and four. Basically, it's going to show
me a double bottom and then it's also
going to be that strong engulfing
candlestick that confirms that. And so,
right here, you can see I'm I'm using
essentially a tool to say, okay, if I
enter here and my stop loss is here, how
much do I want to enter in on the trade?
And then where is, you know, my
risk-reward ratio is going to be. And so
essentially once I wait for that to
confirm, I like to let the next
candlestick play out a little bit
because sometimes a big candlestick like
that can have a little of a bit of a
pullback before it keeps going higher.
Minor detail, but essentially what I'm
looking for now is okay, I'm going to
enter in long at the break of this
pattern and as it goes higher. And so
what I do is you actually see there's no
order here on the screen, but I've
entered in a long here and put my stop
loss down here. The only reason why it
doesn't show up is actually just because
my account on this recording screen
wasn't selected for a little while. But
if we zoom forward, you can see I
entered in here and I put my stop loss
below here. Essentially the bottom of
that swing. The whole idea of why I put
my stop loss there is because I don't
want the market to if the market comes
up here, makes a pretty clean higher
low, and then comes up and breaks that,
I think the trend's going to continue
lower. And so, I just want to kind of
get out because I'm getting mixed
signals. I want the signals for the
trade to be clear and for me to jump in
on the trade. And so, with with this
trade, I think I'm risking about $800.
And so, as we move up, I'm looking at a
few key factors to manage it. And so to
walk you through how I plan to do this
is well obviously the major swing I'd
love to go for is somewhere up here.
That would be holding overnight multiple
days and that's not really what I was
looking for today especially because
it's a Friday. It's going into a long
weekend actually with a holiday on
Monday. Now, obviously, you didn't know
that, but just looking at the patterns
here is well, the market's starting to
kind of slow down. And so, there's
potential resistance zones here where I
think the market could slow down. I also
think a big picture kind of more looking
at a 30 minute is if we look at this,
well, the major kind of swing down it
had when it started to accelerate was
kind of this area right here. And so I
would think a good spot would be to give
uh back up to here if it really started
to get going. And so that's essentially
what I'm doing every time I'm in a trade
is I'm thinking about where are the
potential for not necessarily major. You
don't necessarily need to be targeting a
major swing or a major supply or demand
level, but also looking at these smaller
ones because now that we're in a trade,
those can still reverse the market.
They're not necessarily where I want to
enter in on the market, but they are at
a spot where I want to potentially get
out or take some of the trade off. And
so right here, you can see as the market
started to push up here, it's had a
really nice move. It's essentially given
up this major move down. I have moved my
trade to break even. It's really
important to take that risk off the
table because going forwards, well, I
don't want it to come up here all the
way down and I actually end up losing
$800 on the day when I was up over $800.
That's just kind of, you know, mathwise,
you got to kind of go with that. And the
helpful part is it had this little micro
pullback here. That's when I kind of
moved it up. And then from there, in a
minute here, I put in a limit order at
this high here because I wanted to say I
don't want to manage it in real time. I
want to just get out of half of my trade
of one of my contracts out of my two
when it punches up to this level. And so
right there, you can see it closed. And
so I closed off, took about half my
profits there. And then with the idea is
that I'm buying at the major support
here. I want to see if this will
continue higher and I can get even more
out of this, but I don't want to be
greedy. It's at a definite spot where I
think it can slow down and so I want to
take some off. And so that limit order
that just showed up there, I put it up
here in case we did just skyrocket up
there. That was the spot I wanted to
take the trade off. At that point, I
would have been super happy. I think it
would have been four times my risk in
terms of profit at least for half of
that trade. But going back to the
concepts that we talked about, you can
see I have a trend line here. And this
upwards trend that is going on here is a
very unhealthy or one directional trend.
And so my thought is I'm okay holding
this as long as it holds this trend
line. But as soon as it kind of starts
to break that, it could pull back in a
big way. And at this point, I'm thinking
that, hey, this is a great move. I don't
want to hold through a big pullback. and
push higher. I was able to break up my
trade into maybe having a smaller amount
on here. And so at this point, I was
essentially just watching this and
saying, "Okay, I'm going to get out."
And so, just to zoom forwards here, is
it had a little bit of a bottom here,
move my stop loss up there, and then it
eventually broke that right there. And
so, that's how I take this whole process
and turn it into a step-by-step
checklist that you can now use for
yourself. see the market kind of start
to show kind of a bottoming pattern
right here. It's basically making higher
highs. And so I like this as this
candlestick was a really kind of a big
bearish candlestick attempting the
market to go lower and it failed here
based on these candlesticks. And so I
like the idea of saying, "Hey, I want to
get in long above this candlestick right
here, betting that the market is going
to go higher." And so I put what is
called a buy stop order above it. If the
price of the market touches this price,
put in a market order. I don't care
where you fill me at, just get me in the
market. And most of the time, you can
see it literally just filled at that
exact price. But sometimes it can, you
know, fill you right here because the
market can move pretty fast. But that is
the order I like to enter in on most of
the time. And, you know, you can use a
buy limit order that'll get you in below
or exactly at that price. But the
problem with that is well for this
example right here well the market kind
of took off here and you would have felt
a lot of FOMO and you would have because
you would have missed out on the trade
and you would have had to wait for and
hope that the market comes back down and
fills you at that price. And so you can
see here quickly just over a couple
candlesticks I'm already up $1,000 on
this trade risking you know I think $500
or $600. And so this is where the power
comes into play is I'm trading four oil
futures contracts here. And you can see
it's moving in that 0.01
increment, that penny size, compared to
the S&P 500 futures that we're just
looking at was actually moving in that
quarter of a point size, that 0.25. But
you can see here clearly that the money
is a lot more. And so for me, my
strategy is I like to kind of get in
when I see, you know, basically you can
easily see here is there's a lot of
momentum here. It started to slow down
by essentially just seeing that the
market kind of started to chop here and
then I look for a couple few key factors
to jump in and catch the momentum to the
other side. And so I move my stop here
to break even. And then as this starts
to kind of get pretty accelerated here,
I like to use kind of the idea that,
hey, okay, I'm going to give it a little
bit of wiggle room, but I'm going to
move my stop up if it pulls back
because, you know, I'm up about $2,000.
And, you know, you want to let this
thing run if it's going to run. But you
also, you know, you can see like just as
it pulled back right here, it can
reverse very, very quickly, too. And so,
that's where I really look to, you know,
manage my trades. But again, that's come
with a lot of practice and experience
trading this. You know, my target here,
you can see now that we're getting up to
here. You can see we're kind of in a
support level that I've drawn from
previously in the chart. And that's
where I'm going to expect things to slow
down. And so, you can see I've moved my
stop loss up here. It's, you know, we're
up a lot more money now. And this is
where kind of the power comes into play
of using technical analysis with futures
is you have that leverage and you have
that ease of getting in and out of the
market, but you also have the simplicity
of, you know, you're not having to deal
with the complexity of options and other
factors that come into play with other
assets. And so to just to close this
out, you know, I'm not going to go into
my strategy too much here. I have a lot
more videos on that, but I pretty much
get knocked out right there. So, now
that you know pretty much the nuts and
bolts of this strategy, I want to show
you some live trading examples. These
are recordings of trades I took and me
in real time, not just kind of going
back over and kind of explaining a trade
I took in the past. This is what it's
like in real time. This is super
powerful for you to now understand what
it's like showing up to the morning,
analyzing the market as I see it in real
time, entering a trade, managing a
trade, and going through the emotions
and how I control the emotions and don't
let them control me for a trade and to
be consistently doing this every single
day. Okay. Well, it's time to lock in.
The market is seriously moving this
morning.
uh 15inute chart of NASDAQ. We're coming
up to basically I think that's pretty
much all-time highs. ES is not quite
there, but it's a previous high.
And then
um also we have oil here
is doing a pretty big selloff
kind of just back down to this kind of
support area. Um, so I like it for a
bounce off this big move down. Uh, I
would like a double bottom though to
some extent. It does have news
right here. Um, so
we'll see if that sets something up.
Mainly, honestly, what I'm looking at is
this NASDAQ
move right now is pretty crazy. Um,
we've got news at 8.
Not big news honestly. Uh the 8:30 is
oil. These are you know not west coast
times. Then FOMC
is in a while. So this move will be done
by then.
Um so I just want to see if it kind of
looks like it's going to reverse here at
kind of 45 or 8 a.m. kind of quick early
morning reversal.
See what happens.
Just going to quickly let my room know
what I'm thinking.
I would prefer a five minute, but like
big picture, this is a nice
spot. I really like
that we are at the all-time highs here.
It is a lot of movement strength. I mean
this is broken
but the main thing is that there's
the fair value gap is basically saying
hey it's super overextended.
It's super overextended into oh, sorry,
smaller chart into that previous high.
I mean, even a pullback down to like
here somewhere is great.
It's 54.
This news coming out is,
let's see, pull up this
tool I have. Let's see. It's a wholesale
inventories. So, it
top of the hour wholesale inventories
is not a big release. So, it shouldn't
really matter that much and I can
actually trade through the release.
Um, so that's kind of important to know.
If this sets up beforehand, I can pretty
much say I'll just get in anyway.
So, I might enter in the ES instead.
This move up a lot more. Which one is
up?
So, NASDAQ is up8 this morning while the
ES is up 6. So, it's definitely moving
more,
but I would I would I would like to
trade the weaker one because that's
generally the better way to go.
We got a little bit more of a pullback
than this.
Um 2 minutes on the news.
That's right there.
Just trying to take
I do want to full size this actually
because this is a really nice move
at a good area.
Um
gold actually looks strong. This is gold
on a 15minute. Gold looks like it's
going to bottom
and it's somehow showing strength when
the market is showing strength and so
I think that's kind of helpful for this.
Okay, news is popping up after this
candlestick here.
Um, oil is still kind of doing its
thing. I'm not really concerned about
that right now. I'd rather focus on
this.
Comparing these two, still
the NASDAQ is showing
still more strength while the ES is
showing more weakness.
I do want to be aware that this could
just pull back and shoot continue to
shoot higher. But
again, I want to be aware that that's
okay.
I still want to jump in when a good
signal shows up because
um it's at a good area that makes sense.
You know, I don't know what the market's
going to do. Obviously, I just want to
jump in when it makes sense.
like this is a nice little stab higher.
ENQ is actually making a new high. Wow.
While the ES is not.
So, I think if
NQ looks like it's going to fail,
that's what I want to jump in on.
like this if this fails
like putting in an order below this low
because on a five minute I think that
would still look pretty good on a five
minute
because also big picture if I pull up
targets for this potential.
I mean, it's the the easy money would be
giving this move back up, but then we
could push lower to here, which would be
like this is 3x. This would be like 6x.
Um,
which would be obviously a sick move.
I don't think that's super likely, but
wow. So, that does look good.
I do want to get in short if it but
like I think I want to get short here.
It's just a little nerve-wracking with
the NQ being
But again, like that was a fast move up.
So, I'm nervous about this. But again,
the reasons to get in are good.
NASDAQ,
it could have just got, you know, this
could just be like a final push higher
that fails.
This candlestick right here is pretty
strong. It's just a
an an attempt in a new high and then
it's going to fail.
I would like to see how this does this
kind of bottom here and then continue
higher,
but I think if the NASDAQ gives up, this
is going to push lower.
So, I think I'm going to put an order
below this.
It's a good setup. New high, lower high.
Big picture is good.
And I'm going to put my stop above the
highs
and I'm going to manage
accordingly.
Um,
nice failure there. Again, like the big
thing is this could just come down and
bottom and continue higher.
So,
this point just kind of let it do its
thing. see how it plays out again like
this
looking even on a fivem minute that's a
nice five minute candle
um
but we'll see what it does. Also, if
you're wondering what trading platform
I'm using, it's called Ninja Trader.
I've used it for over 5 years. It's
amazing. I'll leave a link in the
description below this video if you want
to check it out. Okay, I think this is
not going to work cuz let's be honest,
your trades never work.
But it looks good. It looks good in all
reality.
That's a nice little poke higher.
Um, let's look at what
gold looks good.
Pray the gold goes up. That'll help.
Oil.
I don't like oil for I suck at oil longs
honestly.
And when I look at it, this is just I
think FOMO over seeing this move.
Really, the thick entry was this bar
right here and cash that move down.
Otherwise, it was just not worth it.
Um, so I mean like if it bounces, but
it's got it's got news in 20 minutes.
So unlikely.
Again, it's pretty nerve-wracking
cuz there could be just a lot of
strength here and it could just
uh
continue up.
But again, the main thing is it's all
about just following your plan because
this doesn't have to work in every time.
Even if it works 50% of the time and I
get 2x or a little bit off one, like
it's great.
And this still is setting up.
It's still at a decision point. Not out
of the woods, but I think ES looks good.
I'm going to sit on a five minute.
See what that looks like.
I'm going to move it. It's It was not in
a good spot to be frank.
The reason why I like it to be above the
high because if the market came up here
and like let's say
reversed
right here, knocked me out, but then did
a big bar down, I would still want to be
in, but I would have been out of the
trade. Like, it's not violated until it
breaks up here.
It can come up here and then do a failed
breakout back, failed
selloff back in, but usually that's
unlikely.
So, this
is not selling off quickly. I would say
it doesn't look good.
I think if this
lower high here on the NASDAQ doesn't
turn into head and shoulders and start
going down, I'm going to want to get out
because at that point, it just looks
like it's probably going to continue
higher.
I'm just going to go step away for a
while because this is driving me a
little crazy
and I think it's going to not work out
even though NQ is actually making more
lows.
NQ looks better
than the ES now. But
this trading, we got to sit here in the
agony
of indecision.
I think because of it being kind of like
this once it gets to break even or 1x I
think I'm gonna go break even
unless it just gets moving quickly.
This is when just looking at a a bigger
picture five minute chart just makes it
way easier to
to drown out the noise.
of it
looking good or or looking bad.
We're just looking for a push. Of
course, the NASDAQ is now selling off
better.
Classic. You choose one and the other is
better. Um,
now I'll just turn this on to for kicks.
I want to move to break even now because
if it just shoots up after that, I'm
just going to get out. Like, just get me
out of that. Um, I'm going to take off
2x for sure
down here. If it just blips lower.
Yeah, just that's a nice start. It could
totally just reverse up after that
though.
Would it suck to just get out
at break even? Yeah,
after all that. But
as a part of trading,
all right, we're I'm looking for this
move. It has stabbed through most of
this
move already, which is kind of rough,
but I can also if it starts to slow
down, I'll trail a little bit. Like I'll
trail previous candlestick.
I'm just going to give it a minute here
and see.
Got to manage my stupid recording pages.
Okay, I'm going to trail with two
with the previous candlestick
that looks like it's just going to
basically not get knocked out.
O
I really want to pull this down.
It literally just almost blipped it.
[Applause]
Okay, it filled that. My computer is
literally lagging.
Okay,
I'm moving the rest down here.
So, 2x
I want to give it some room, but also
like
I'm not going to give it, you know,
crazy room here.
There we go. That's fine room right
there.
I'm going to give it I'm going to give
it this candlestick because it's clearly
ENQ hasn't even given the move back up.
Big picture. Pulling up the 15minute
chart again just to see where we're at.
Again, the easy money is kind of over,
but I don't So, and so it's like I'm
giving it some room, but also like I'm
not going to give it like one, you know,
a crazy amount. Like this is the move
I'm really looking for. I'm not really
looking for this. Like that's more if it
just rips lower,
you know?
[Applause]
Sick trade
that just came out of nowhere. I was not
expecting that to happen after this
chop. I was like, I'm screwed. I've lost
for the day.
Um,
well, okay. Okay. Okay, so the market
has been open for 15 minutes here and
looking at the NASDAQ futures and the ES
futures. The NASDAQ has a pretty good
uptrend in place as well with the ES and
so I would say there isn't really
great constructive support levels. You
know, we might come down here and
bounce. Looks like we're kind of selling
off right now, but if you look at both
of them, we had a really nice move up
yesterday in a sell-off,
but right now it's just kind of chopping
um in this bigger sideways trend still.
NASDAQ has broken out a little bit more.
Um so it's definitely looking on the
bullish side overall, but also kind of
weak at the same time. And so in my
eyes, that's kind of just indecision.
and so makes me less likely to want to
touch it. Um, gold here is having a
kind of zoomed out on a 15 is having a
big move up here. It's kind of been
chopping around for a while, but now
it's had a big move yesterday and this
morning it's having a second one um and
going down into a fivem minute. Like
this is a nice uptrend that I would love
to try and short, but the problem is if
we zoom out to like a 30, there's just
not a great
level that it's at yet. You know, I'd
love it was if it was popping up here,
here there it's, you know, kind of had
some chop and there's some previous
tops over here,
but it's still just not great. And so
I'll look at it and see, you know, watch
it and see, okay, well, does it set up a
really nice clean looking like double
top kind of situation where I can at
least catch a move down to here,
especially like maybe on a one minute
chart if it looks like it'll reverse a
little quicker.
And then oil is just kind of crappy
looking. Um, it's just kind of in the
middle of the zone. Maybe if it pops
down to here, but at the moment its
current trend is just kind of just a
sloppy downtrend.
You know, that's not interesting. You
know, I want to see something
overextended
and, you know, popping up a bunch of
fair value gap indicators on like a
50-minute chart. Um, like oil, I mean,
gold here. I mean, this is that's a that
was a 30 minute technically, but you
know, again, very one directional
getting overextended. It's going to have
to have a pullback at some point. That's
the main thing. There's also
some news
30 minutes after the market opens. Uh,
in terms of of severity, it says it's
orange. I think this one actually is
um Richmond M
Richmond manufacturing index is actually
green from my
sheet. So theoretically it's not that
big of a deal. Um but it will be up here
in like 10 minutes. So I'm kind of
waiting to see that. See if we can get a
reversal
in the NASDAQ. I think that's kind of
the biggest option at the moment. Um
especially after this reversing off of
that because we're just kind of in a
sideways range. There's also this low.
They're not great lows to be reversing
off of because we haven't like tested it
multiple times.
But with these early morning reversals,
sometimes that's all you need. And so
I'm okay watching that and taking a
quick stab on those on a one minute
chart.
Okay, this has sold off really fast on
the NASDAQ. And generally when this
happens, it could vb bottom and I'll
totally miss it. But also, we've broken
below this low. I like we could totally
get a failed breakout here, but I want
to see if I'm going to take a long, I
need to see how it comes up and tests
this level because otherwise it could
just come up here and keep selling off.
And with when there's this much momentum
in in this case, it's you don't want to
just try and jump in long out of the
fear that oh there's, you know, a ton of
cra this crazy move down and I can, you
know, catch the whole swing up kind of
thing. That's not what we're looking
for.
I didn't get long on this initial candle
because I it just needs to kind of break
with the overall
bullishness or or bearishness happening.
I almost need like a higher low here.
Even though this is technically a higher
low,
just having a little bit more
confirmation would be good. Um
the sizing here isn't
great.
for
half size. I'll probably double the
contracts to go like 600 risk which
would end up being like 700.
But I mean overall like
just doesn't look great. And this is how
you weed out crappy or not great trades
when you're unsure.
But if this comes down here and pops up,
I want to get long.
And I think I want to get long two
contracts
because that's what I was just looking
for. And I think that's a good enough
confirmation.
You know, I'll be nervous about it
because
I'm a little back and forth on the read,
but I think this is a good spot to jump
in long because of this double bottom we
have. We've hit a
a low from I think this is couple days
ago kind of Friday.
Um
and so we are in long. Just going to
pull my stop up below this double
bottom. And I'm probably just going to
go for
2x here. Um just because the market is
pretty choppy.
Uh, I'm just going to switch up this
indicator here.
I'm kind of having some issues with it
lately just to show my actual
risk and profit. So, I'm I'm smaller
size than normal, kind of half sized.
Um, mainly because this was pretty
bearish move. And
the level is
it's it's like kind of like the first
retest. But what I like is we have these
fair value gap indicators on a 5m minute
and the timing with 8:00 reversal is
pretty solid. And then a double bottom
here. And so I think it looks good for a
nice move up.
And I'm only going to go for 2x just
because
of this bearishness that we're having.
Um, also I've been sleeping like crap.
So,
um, I just won't be making as good
decisions tech potentially.
This is just a pullback. I'm probably
going to have to hold back. Hold
through. I mean, I think with the with
the way this trend is, it needs to have
this double bottom. And then some kind
of fake lower.
Um once this kind of breaks up here, I
think to break to 1x here, I'll probably
move here and maybe break even if this
really looks like it's going to start to
get going. um just because I think it's
either it's this is a really nice
constructive setup now and I think it's
either it's probably gonna rip back up
here or it's going to come up here at
50% here and and continue lower with the
big picture
bearishness
taken into a play. And you know, again,
I'm just looking for this quick reversal
in the morning. Um and I don't want to
put risk on the table if it's just going
to not really do what I want it to do.
I will say this does not look great.
Part of me wants to
move my stop up here,
take the risk off
because we haven't had a fast bounce.
And it feels like it seems like the
downtrend could pick up. But also
in terms of big picture five minute, we
can still totally come down here
and bounce. Got a five minute on there,
five minute on here. I mean like it
would still be totally intact. Um, and
then if I got out at break even and I
saw a bullish candlestick form right
here,
I'd be like, "Oh, I wish I was in that."
Because
it it set up a very clean double bottom
on a five minute. And so I just have to
even though I'm feeling that doubt and
nervousness because it is kind of
choppy.
Um I'm just going to hold and because
the main big picture of the trade isn't
violated yet.
Is there the risk that it goes down?
Yes. And I lose? Yes.
But I don't want to get out because I'm
nervous
when there's no real market reason to
get out. You know, riskreward is there.
Um, and the big picture of of moving up
and giving back that snap down we had
from the market open is totally
possible. And so it, you know, I think
once we break this is pretty much like a
little double top right here. Once we
break that,
I will move to break even at that point
because at that point it's it's had its
pullback that it should have in an
uptrend
and I'll want to get out at that point.
But right now it's just had this is the
first push higher and it could continue
higher after a pullback. Like a NASDAQ
here made a new high versus the ES
actually didn't. It basically made a
double top. Um, so just kind of waiting
for that to play out and
that's kind of the hard part about
trading.
Okay, we're getting a pop here. So, I'm
going to move to break even. Now,
sometimes I would move to the this low,
but if it pulls back off of that, I'm
just going to get out. Um NASDAQ is
similar
the five minutes like this is the fivem
minute pullback I was looking for like
I would have still wanted to been been
in if I got scared and got out there you
know the trade wasn't violated. Um
with the way the market is it could
still just
pull back and knock me out of break
even. But again
just managing it I don't know what's
going to happen. I would love to take
2x,
but we'll just have to see.
So, as this gets going here and I get
close to this 2x target, I'm going to
especially once we get up to here, like
once we start getting a candle up here,
up to this price somewhere, I'm going to
move my stop loss up pretty aggressively
because there's no point in letting it
come up here and then rip all the way
back down, right? I'd rather just try
and get 2x at the most. But if it's just
going to come up here and pull back, I'd
rather just get out at like one and a
half. Um because this is a big move up
in, you know, a quick move to give this
back up, which is great, but it's been
kind of a a slow market. And so this
could really just reverse anytime at now
at this point. Um I you know it it looks
really good to keep going higher. But
again big picture 50% pullback is
um based on this is just this dot right
here is literally right here on the
NASDAQ. So we're at the 50%. Um and ES
is
past the 50%. So,
I would love for this to keep going
higher. And I think if that's going to
happen, it's got this tight trend that
it's going to hold. And so, I'm going to
move up actually to 1x here. I really
almost don't want to because I don't
want it to come down here, knock me out,
and keep going higher.
But in terms of managing it tightly and
having this more fixed riskreward of
well I I only have a little bit more
profit to make. There's no point in you
know risking essentially $1,000
um to make you know another $400. That's
kind of how the math adjusts as your
trade goes. Um and so
I don't want to give all that back up.
Um, and and it doesn't make sense
mathwise. Um, and so hopefully it holds
this, but again, it looks like it could
just have a pullback here. Um, and you
know, I could have it down here, but you
know what? I am I'm still happy if I get
1x on a trade. Um, it's a long, which is
harder to play. It was half size, so I
wasn't really super confident in it to
begin with. Um,
and so I can be super bummed, but I'll
be a little bummed just because it does
look good, but again, it's it's given
back a lot of the move and it's not the
market's just not acting great in terms
of strength. Um, NASDAQ here, that's a
little bit nicer of a bottom to hold.
Um, but again, like I think this is ES
is going to hold this and and keep going
higher if it's going to hold. But this
uptrend is already kind of broken.
So
five minute NASDAQ just looks cleaner.
But again, this is this is where I'm at.
Okay, out for 700.
Still happy about it. Still a nice
trade. you know jumped in smaller size
because of
how I felt about it and you know if it
if it just shoots lower here I will be
very happy that I got out
you know I don't want to play this
struggle game of waiting for it to
continue higher slowly over and over
time not every day is going to be you
know amazing follow your strategy go
with what your read is that's all you
can do and so make sure to download that
14page free candlestick patterns guide
in the link in the description of this
video or with this QR code right here.
It'll really help you consistently
execute this strategy and show you more
patterns that I use to enter in on other
than the quick ones I just went through.